GOOD AFTERNOON.
THIS WILL BEGIN TODAY'S SUB ONE
HEARING ON APRIL TWENTY FIFTH
TWENTY EIGHTEEN.
RECOGNIZING THAT WE HAVE
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LEVINE HERE I'D
LIKE TO TAKE HIM FIRST AND THEN
WE'LL RETURN TO THE TOP OF THE
ORDER. SO WE WILL FIRST DEAL
WITH ISSUE FIVE.
MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR.
ALLOWING MEDIA TO PRY TESTIMONY
IT WITH MY WITNESSES WHO ARE.
GOING BE CATCHING FLIGHTS LATER
TODAY I REALLY APPRECIATE IT.
THE CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE
JEWISH CAUCUS WOULD LIKE THE
BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE TO ADOPT A
THREE POINT ONE SIX MILLION
DOLLAR APPROPRIATION TO THE
DEPARTMENT. OF SOCIAL SERVICES
FOR A HOLOCAUST SURVIVOR
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM.
JEWISH FAMILY SERVICE AGENCIES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE CURRENTLY
SERVE OVER THREE THOUSAND THREE
HUNDRED SURVIVORS EACH YEAR.
WHO RELY ON ESSENTIAL SERVICES
TO LIVE INDEPENDENTLY?
WHILE THE SIZE OF THIS IS
SURVIVOR POPULATION IS
DECREASING
AS A AS THEY AGE AND THEY PASSED
AWAY. THE NUMBER OF SURVIVORS
NEEDING ASSISTANCE IS ALSO
GROWING.
THIS ONE TIME APPROACH
APPROPRIATION ESTABLISH A GRANT
PROGRAM TO HELP THESE
INDIVIDUALS AVOID
INSTITUTIONALIZATION.
BY PROVIDING SERVICES SUCH AS
HOME CARE CULTURALLY APPROPRIATE
CASE MANAGEMENT HOME DELIVERED
MEALS TRANSPORTATION AND
EMERGENCY FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE.
HOLOCAUST SURVIVORS IN
CALIFORNIA ARE INCREASINGLY
FRAIL AND VULNERABLE. AND THEY
HAVE UNMET NEEDS RELATED TO HOME
CARE NUTRITION TRANSPORTATION
HOUSING. EXISTING AGING
COMMUNITY BASED SERVICES ARE
INADEQUATE AND ADDITIONAL STATE
RESOURCES ARE NEEDED TO ENSURE
HOLOCAUST SURVIVORS CAN LIVE
OUT.
THEIR FINAL YEARS WITH DIGNITY.
WITH ME TO TESTIFY TODAY IS
ACTUALLY HARRINGTON MANAGER OF
PUBLIC AFFAIRS THE JEWISH FAMILY
SERVICE OF SAN DIEGO. AND NANCY
VOLPERT DIRECTOR OF PUBLIC
POLICY STRATEGIC IN THIS YEAR
INITIATIVES WITH JEWISH FAMILY
SERVICES OF LOS ANGELES.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON I'M NANCY
VOLPERT I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF
JFS AS AS ASSEMBLY MEMBER LIVING
MENTION. WE ARE THE OLDEST
CHARITY AND LOS ANGELES AND WE
PROVIDE A RANGE OF SERVICES TO
PEOPLE OF ALL BACKGROUNDS AGES
ETHNICITIES.
EACH YEAR IN CAO IN LOS ANGELES
SERVING ABOUT A HUNDRED THOUSAND
PEOPLE A YEAR.
AND WE'RE HERE TODAY WITH THE
REALLY URGENT REQUEST.
LAST WEEK AS YOU KNOW AS THE
ANNUAL HOLOCAUST REMEMBRANCE
CEREMONY HERE AT THE CAPITOL.
AND MANY OF YOU SAW AND WE HAVE
WORKED WITH YOUR OFFICE HONEST
FEWER AND FEWER SURVIVORS WERE
ABLE TO MAKE THE TRIP THIS YEAR.
THEY'RE BECOMING MORE FRAIL AND
LESS ABLE TO TRAVEL AND WE SEE
THIS REALITY EVERYDAY AT JFS.
FORCING THE LONG TERM
CONSEQUENCES OF THE LIFE FORGED
IN TRAUMA.
THESE.
PEOPLE SURVIVED UNIMAGINABLE
FOR.
THE TEENAGERS AND CHILDREN WHO
SURVIVED ARE NOW IN THEIR
EIGHTIES AND NINETIES NO LONGER
PROVIDING CARE FOR OTHERS BUT
NEEDING CARE THEMSELVES.
SO I THOUGHT I WOULD TELL YOU
THE STORY OF ROSA ONE OF OUR
CLIENTS.
SO.
YOU CAN SEE A PICTURE OF WHO
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT IN NINETEEN
FORTY WHEN RUSSELL WAS TWELVE.
THE HOLOCAUST HER AND HER FAMILY
OUT OF HER HOME IN AUSTRIA.
SHORTLY AFTER THAT.
UP HER PARENTS WERE BOTH
EXECUTED.
EVENTUALLY AFTER THE WAR SHE AND
HER HUSBAND MADE IT TO THE
UNITED STATES.
SHE'S NOW NINETY YEARS OLD.
SHE'S VERY FRAIL SHE'S GOT MANY
HEALTH PROBLEMS INCLUDING
MYELOMA.
AND SHE HAS ONGOING CHEMOTHERAPY
AND HEALTH TREATMENTS AND
MEDICAL ISSUES.
SHE ALSO LOST HER HUSBAND FIVE
YEARS AGO.
SHE IS.
SUPPORTED EMOTIONALLY BY HER SON
AND DAUGHTER IN LAW.
BUT THEY DON'T HAVE THE
RESOURCES EITHER TO MEET ALL HER
NEEDS.
SHE NEEDS RICK ASSISTANCE WITH
PERSONAL CARE. WITH HOUSEHOLD
CHORES.
SHE'S ON MEDI CAL SHE RECEIVES
IIHS ASKS AT STILL NOT ENOUGH
FOR HER TO REMAIN SAFELY AT
HOME.
SHE LIVES ON A LOW FIXED INCOME
CAN'T AFFORD HER GROCERIES.
I CAN'T AFFORD BASIC LOADING
SUPPLIES.
THANKS SIR JOSEPH HER JAFFA
SOCIAL WORKER SHE'S RECEIVING
EVERY BIT OF HELP THAT WE CAN
FIND. PRIVATE PUBLIC STATE
FEDERAL WE CAN FIND IT SHE'S
ACCESSING IT.
BUT SHE'S JUST ONE OF A THOUSAND
SURVIVORS THAT WE'RE PROVIDING
CARE TO EACH YEAR AT JEFF SLI.
AND THEY'RE MORE THAN TWO
HUNDRED ADDITIONAL SURVIVORS FOR
ON WAIT LISTS FOR CARE FROM US.
BECAUSE WE DON'T HAVE THOSE
RESOURCES.
AND SO AS WE LOOK AROUND THE
STATE AND WE SEE THE NUMBER OF
SURVIVORS LIVING IN POVERTY.
WE THINK THAT WITH YOUR HELP AND
THE CALIFORNIA HOLOCAUST
SURVIVORS ASSISTANCE FUND WE CAN
MAKE A DIFFERENCE IN THEIR
LIVES.
IN THEIR LIVES THAT ARE.
NEARING THEIR AND.
BUT.
THEY DESERVE TO LIVE IT OUT WITH
RESPECT AND DIGNITY.
THEY SURVIVE TRAUMA LIKE NONE OF
US CAN EVER IMAGINE. AND WE OWE
THEM AN.
A DUTY OF CARE AND RESPECT AND
WE APPRECIATE YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
THE HUMAN.
HI MY NAME'S ASHLEY HARRINGTON I
REPRESENT JEWISH FAMILY SERVICE
IN SAN DIEGO. AS ASSEMBLYMEMBER
LEVINE AND NANCY MENTIONED WE'VE
ACTUALLY SEEN IN AND SAN DIEGO A
DRAMATIC INCREASE IN THE NUMBER
OF SURVIVORS TURNING OR AGENCY
FOR HELP. IN THE LAST TWO YEARS
WE'VE SEEN A FIFTY PERCENT
INCREASE IN THE NUMBER OF
SURVIVORS WHO HAVE OUTLIVED
THEIR RESOURCES WHO HAVE
DRAMATICALLY INCREASED SAYING.
NEEDS WHO ARE TURNING OR AGENCY
FOR HELP FOR THE FIRST TIME.
THIS PROGRAM WOULD ESTABLISH A
VARIETY OF SERVICES THAT
AGENCIES WITH EXPERTISE IN
PERSON CENTERED TRAUMA INFORMED
CARE. THAT HAVE A RECORD OF
SURVIVING HOPES OTHER SERVING
HOLOCAUST SURVIVORS COULD
PROVIDE THESE UNMET NEEDS ME
THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION.
THANK YOU.
NEXT ON OUR LIST OF PRESENTERS
WE HAVE DIRECTOR LIGHT BORN AND
WANTED TO GIVE HIM AN
OPPORTUNITY IF HE HAD A COMMENT.
SOARING MISTER CHAIR LITTLE SLOW
GETTING UP HERE ALL OF.
THANK YOU MISTER OR COMMITTEE
ARM WILL LIKE BORN DIRECTOR OF
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT SOCIAL
SERVICES. WE HAD AN OPPORTUNITY
TO MEET THIS MORNING WITH THE
SPONSORS ALL OF THIS PROPOSAL.
AND DEFERRED SO PRIORITY.
IN THE BUDGET PROCESS WILL
CERTAINLY WORK CLOSELY WITH
THEM.
HOME TO LOOK AT MEANS OF
IMPLEMENTATION.
THANK YOU DIRECTOR DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE LA WHEN IT COMES NEARLY
WITH FINANCE WE HAVEN'T HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO MAKE WHAT THE.
AND PERHAPS THE PROPOSAL THAT
THEY CURRICULA. THIS AT THE
MOMENT BUT.
I AM LIKE LIKE WHAT DOCTOR AT
DIRECTORS LIKE WHEN THE STATE
TOOK THAT SIR.
PRIORITY NUMBER CAN.
ABOUT.
WE WILL NOT TAKE PUBLIC COMMENT
ON ISSUE FIVE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN CLIFF
BURKE YOUR BEHALF FOR THE JEWISH
PUBLIC AFFAIRS COMMITTEE WANTED
TO REGISTER A STRONG SUPPORT FOR
THIS BUDGET PROPOSAL. IS I THINK
A PRIORITY FOR OUR STATE TO TAKE
CARE OF OUR IMMIGRANTS HOLOCAUST
SURVIVORS CLEARLY THE ORIGINAL
IMMIGRANTS OR. ONE OF THE FIRST
IMMIGRANT POPULATIONS TO COME TO
CALIFORNIA AS A RESULT OF A
TREMENDOUS AN UNSPEAKABLE
HORRORS IN EUROPE. AND THEY
DESERVE THE STATE'S COMMITMENT
AND SUPPORT TO HELP THEM TO THE
FINAL. DAYS OF THEIR WATER YEARS
HOPEFULLY OF THEIR LIVES SO WE
APPRECIATE YOUR SUPPORT THANK
YOU THANK YOU SIR.
KEVIN AS THE COLD IS A
CALIFORNIA WELFARE RIGHTS
ORGANIZATION STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
TING NO FURTHER PUBLIC COMMENT
ON BRING IT UP TO THE DYESS
SOMEONE RUBIO THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR A FOUR.
BEING HERE TODAY I JUST WANT TO.
AGAIN THANK YOU FOR FOR YOUR
ADVOCACY AND APPRECIATE YOU
COMING BEFORE US I DO HAVE A
COUPLE REQUESTS.
IN WE SPOKE EARLIER TODAY MY
OFFICE AND I AT ALL I WOULD LIKE
TO ASK IS YOU KNOW HOW WE'RE
ASSESSING. ON THE VOTE BUT CARE
THAT'S GOING TO BE PROVIDED AND
HOW MANY FIGHTERS YOU'RE GONNA
NEED IF YOU CAN GIVE ME SOME.
SOME DATA SO THAT WE CAN TRACK
IT AND THEN YOU KNOW I HOPE WILL
HELP YOU WITH THE THE BUDGET ASK
THIS YEAR AND IF WE NEED TO
INCREASE AT THE FOLLOWING YOUR
IF WE CAN GIVE. GET SOME
CONCRETE DATA AS TO.
HOW MANY PEOPLE YOUR SURVEYING
AND?
COMING MORE PROVIDERS YOU'RE
GONNA NEED OR. WHAT THIS MONEY'S
GONNA PAY FOR AND IN THAT WAY WE
CAN TRACK FOR THE?
THE HOPEFULLY NON GOING.
.
SHOULD I SAY THAT I AM I REQUEST
AMONG GOING REQUEST FOR
SERVICES.
THANK YOU.
I ALSO WANT TO THANK YOU SOME
REMEMBER LEVINE FOR BRINGING
THIS TIMELY AND IMPORTANT
MEASURE FORWARD.
I WANTED TO SHARE I THINK IT'S
NICE WHEN YOU'RE ACTUALLY ABLE
TO SHARE A PERSONAL STORY AND
ALLOW US TO.
SEE ROSA WHERE SHE IS NOW AND SO
WITH THAT WE WILL HOLD THIS
ISSUE OPEN FOR NOW AND. LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING THE
CONVERSATION THANK YOU FOR
COMING THINK THINK YOU'RE MUCH
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS I
APPRECIATE THAT.
INTEREST IN AN ON GOING.
.
IT'S JUST A MATTER OF LIFE THAT
IT IT WON'T BE ON GOING.
AND DIE AND IN THAT DISPUTE THE
SURVIVORS THAT WE ARE FORTUNATE
TO HAVE. WITH US TODAY.
BAIT THEY WON'T BE WITH US
FOREVER.
INTO THIS IS A ONE TIME REQUEST
AT TO HELP ESTABLISH THIS
PROGRAM AND DIED.
AND SO WE WITNESS WOULD NOT BE
SOMETHING THAT WOULD BE.
A PROGRAM FOR THE STATE TO HAVE
IN PERPETUITY FOREVER.
NO BUT SHE TOLD ME THAT THEY
HAVE A OF A PERSON THE HUNDRED
AND FOR ALTHOUGH YOU DON'T KNOW
IT I DON'T WE WANT TO KEEP THEM
AS LONG AS WE CAN. AND AND SO I.
.
YOU KNOW TO TO NANCY'S POINT
ABOUT HOW I MEAN AND THAT THE
SIX YEARS THAT I'VE PARTICIPATED
HOLOCAUST REMEMBRANCE CEREMONY.
OTHERS FEWER OF THEM THEIR MORE
FRAIL. AT THE EVENT.
EACH YEAR WE OFTEN HAVE SOMEONE
WHO DOES GO TO THE HOSPITAL.
THAT DAY.
FROM FROM THE CEREMONY AND AND
AND FROM THE EVENT.
IT'S WE NOTICE THAT DIED
PHYSICALLY IN AND EVEN A PROP
SPIRITUALLY.
THAT THAT THAT THE GRASP THAT.
BUT WE HAVE FUN ON THEM AS
MEMBERS OF OUR COMMUNITY IS
SAYING THAT WE'RE LOSING. AND
DIE AND SO THIS PROGRAM WELL.
.
MAKE UP CONCRETE THAT NOT ONLY
DO WE REMEMBER OTHER HOT
HOLOCAUST BUT ALSO OF THE DUTY
OF CARE.
THAT WAS SPOKEN THAT WE HAVE TO
PEOPLE SO THANK YOU SO MUCH
COMMITTEE AND THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
WE WILL NOW RETURN TO THE TOP OF
OUR AGENDA HERE TODAY.
AND START WITH ISSUE ONE
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
MERCY.
MY NAME IS MATT SCHULER I'M THE
CHIEF DEPUTY DIRECTOR WITH THE
OFFICES SYSTEMS INTEGRATION.
AND.
WERE IN FRONT OF YOU TODAY TO
DISCUSSSOME OF OUR PROPOSALS.
AND ALSO TO GIVE YOU AN UPDATE
ON SOME OF THE AUTOMATION
PROJECTS THAT WE HAVE WITHIN OUR
PORTFOLIO FOR THE HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES AGENCY.
THERE'RE THREE.
PROJECTS THAT YOU'D LIKE STATUS
UPDATES ON.
.
IF YOU DON'T MIND I'D LIKE TO
START WITH THE EPT PROJECT.
AND GIVE YOU AN UPDATE ON THAT
TIME I HAVE.
.
STEAM DUDLEY OUR DEPUTY DIRECTOR
OVER THAT AREA TO GIVE YOU AN
UPDATE.
CHAIR COMMITTEE EBT SIGNED A
CONTRACT WITH FIS IN OUR JUNE OF
TWENTY SIXTEEN POOR EBT SERVICES
WE SPENT THE LAST YEAR AND A
HALF BEGINNING. TO DO ALL THE
WORK TO TRANSITION FROM OUR
CURRENT VENDOR TO THAT NEW
VENDOR. ALONG THE WAY WE COUNTED
SOME CHALLENGES AND IT RESULTED
IN A.
.
DETERMINATION THAT WE NEED SOME
ADDITIONAL TIME SO WHILE YOUR
AGENDA SAYS THAT IT WAS PLANNED
TO BE IMPLEMENTED JANUARY TWENTY
EIGHTEEN THAT DATE HAS BEEN
MOVED. UP TO JUNE OF THIS YEAR.
ACTUALLY THE WEEKEND IS JUNE
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE TWENTY
FOUR.
THERE WAS NO IMPACT THE BUDGET
OVER THAT SHIFT WAS JUST A SHIFT
IN THE SCHEDULE.
SO ALL OF THE THINGS THAT WERE
CAUSING THE DELAY HAVE BEEN
COMPLETED WE ARE CURRENTLY IN
THE LAST STAGES OF USER
ACCEPTANCE TESTING. ADAM.
AND WHAT ELSE ARE YOU A TI USER
ACCEPTANCE TESTING IS SCHEDULED
TO BE COMPLETED THIS WEEK NEXT
WEEK OUR FEDERAL PARTNERS UP IN
S. WILL BE HERE TO DO THEIR
ACCEPTANCE TESTING. AND THEN THE
FOLLOWING WEEK THERE WILL BE
TESTING WITH THE CONSORTIA TO
TEST THE SYSTEM AND AND.
AND THEN THE.
THAT WILL BE OUR LAST TEST AND
THEN WILL BE READY TO MAKE THE
DECISION WHETHER TO GO LIVE OR
NOT GREAT. THANK YOU.
PERFECT.
AND THEN NEXT I THINK WE'D LIKE
TO COVER THE A CASE MANAGEMENT
INFORMATION AND A ROLLING SYSTEM
AND I ALSO HAVE OUR. DEPUTY
DIRECTOR FOR THAT AREA CYNTHIA
TALKATIVE BUT NOT TODAY EITHER
OKAY SO SEEMS TO I THINK THE THE
ITEM OF THE BIGGEST NOTE WE'RE
HER LAST YEAR WAS WE WERE IN
PROCUREMENT.
WE'VE ACTUALLY COMPLETED A A
COMPETITIVE PROCUREMENT.
AND WE HAVE. SELECTED.
A NEW VENDOR.
SO WITH THAT WE HAVE HAD DONE
NEGOTIATIONS WITH THE VENDOR AND
ARE MOVING FORWARD TO GET
APPROVAL FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT. ARE WITH REGARDS TO
THE CONTRACT AND WE'RE LOOKING
AT A PIECE
CONTRA EXECUTION DATE OF
APPROXIMATELY JULY ONE.
THAT WILL INITIATE TRANSITION
PERIOD WE HAVE AN ESTIMATED TIME
OF EIGHT MONTHS FOR TRANSITION
FROM.
V. I CURRENT VENDOR TO THE NEW
AND I KNOW SERVICES UNDER.
SO WE'RE LOOKING AT WITH THAT
STARTING IN JULY THAT WE WOULD
BE DONE.
ROUGHLY AND THE JANUARY
FEBRUARY TIME PERIOD. AND WE'RE
LOOKING JUST JUST FOR NO FOR
LOOKING AT DOING IT.
IN A PHASED APPROACH IS NOT
LIKE.
GO ALL THE WAY TO THE AND IN
THAT IT TO SWITCHES WILL BE
LOOKING AT.
TRANSFERRING OR TRANSITIONING.
SERVICES FROM ONE VENDOR TO
ANOTHER IN ORDER TO HAVE A
METHODICAL APPROACH OVER THE
EIGHT MONTH PERIOD.
GREAT.
I THINK THE THIRD PROGRAMS CWS
CARES IF IT.
AND.
.
I WAS WAITING FOR OUR DEPUTY
DIRECTOR OVER THAT AREA TO.
COME IN AND HELP ME PROVIDE THE
TESTIMONY BUT I'M WE CAN GO
AHEAD AND ADDRESS THAT.
SHE MUST BE HAVING PARKING
ISSUES POTENTIALLY.
SO THE SICK. OR ELEVATOR ISSUES
THAT BUT YOU.
SO ANYWAY WITHOUT.
FURTHER DELAY ON THE CW YES
CARES PROJECT IS THE EFFORT
THAT.
THE ADMINISTRATION HAS
UNDERTAKEN.
ON BEHALF OF.
OR SPONSOR THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES
AND ALSO IN VERY DIRECT
COORDINATION WITH THE COUNTY
IT'S TO BE ABLE TO PROVIDE.
CHILD WELFARE WORKERS THE TOOLS
THEY NEED IN ORDER TO BE ABLE TO
HELP CALIFORNIA'S MOST
VULNERABLE CHILDREN.
AND.
BUT LAST YEAR WE GAVE YOU.
INFORMATION ON THE CHANGE IN
THE APPROACH OF THAT PROJECT
WHERE BEFORE WE ARE APPROACHING
IT FROM THE STANDPOINT OF USING
A MONOLITHIC.
APPROACH TO PROCURE SINGLE
VENDOR.
WE HAVE NOW TAKEN THE APPROACH
TO DO YOU THINK A.
ITERATIVE APPROACH INVOLVING
MULTIPLE VENDORS AND AND
BUILDING MODULES IN ORDER TO
PROVIDE THOSE DIGITAL SERVICES.
SO I'M.
WHERE WE CURRENTLY STAND RIGHT
NOW IS WE HAVE DELIVERED?
THEY.
A MEASURE OF FUNCTIONALITY HOW.
AS SPECIFIC TO INTAKE I'M IN
TERMS OF SNAPSHOT I'M WHAT WE
CALL SNAPSHOT AND THAT IS AN
ELASTIC SEARCH FUNCTION. THAT
ALLOWS USERS TO BE ABLE TO RUN
SEARCHES MUCH MORE QUICKLY THAN
THE EXISTING. CASE MANAGEMENT
SYSTEM.
SO THE.
.
BUT WE ARE IN THE PROCESS OF NOW
I MAKING THAT MORE EXTENSIBLE TO
A WIDER RANGE OF USERS AND THAT
ULTIMATELY THE DIET ENTIRE
POPULATION OF STATE USERS.
ARM. IN ADDITION WE ARE ALSO
WORKING ON.
THAT FUNCTIONALITY FOR.
CASE MANAGEMENT FOR.
DE AYE CHILD AND ADOLESCENT
NEEDS AND STRENGTHS ASSESSMENT
WHICH IS PART OF THE CONTINUUM
OF CARE REFORM. WE CONTINUE TO
WORK ON THAT AND OTHER DIGITAL
SERVICES.
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WE HAVE
ALSO DONE IS WE HAVE BEEN FACED
WITH SOME MEASURE OF CHALLENGES
IN ORDER TO BE ABLE DELIVER.
WORKING CODE ON A CONSISTENT
BASIS SO ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
WE'RE DOING IN ORDER TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE ARE ABLE TO DO THAT
IS WE'VE HAD.
SEVERAL ASSESSMENTS THAT HAVE
BEEN DONE.
WE'VE BEEN WORKING IN CLOSE
COOPERATION WITH THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF TECHNOLOGY.
IN ORDER TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
HAVE THAT CAPABILITY IS WHAT WE
CALL MORE BUILDING THE FACTORY.
SO WE HAVE THE INFRASTRUCTURE
THAT WE NEED IN ORDER TO BE ABLE
TO RELEASE THAT CODE.
TO THE WORKERS ON THAT ERROR
BRACED BASIS.
SO WE HAVE.
UNDER WAY UP A LOT OF TECHNICAL
IMPROVEMENTS TO THAT PIPELINE
SAID THAT WE HAVE AUTOMATED
PROPAGATION OF ENVIRONMENTS.
AUTOMATED TESTING AND BEING ABLE
TO FACILITATE.
THE DELIVERY OF THAT CODE.%
SO I'M ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
YOU'LL NOTE IN THE AGENDA IS
THAT.
.
WE ARE WORKING TO.
WE ARE WORKING TO FIX.
CASE OF DELIVERY.
AND AGAIN REALLY DELIVER THAT
VALUABLE WORKING CODE TO THE
PEOPLE THAT NEED IT.
GREAT.
BERMAN FINANCE.
ELIOT.
I DON'T THAT'S WHAT I LOOK AT
THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
WE DON'T HAVE PARTICULAR ISSUES
TO RAISE FOR THE COMMITTEE ON
THE PROJECTS WITHIN OVERSIZE
PORTFOLIO THAT ARE DISCUSSED
HERE. BUT JUST AS NOTED IN THE
AGENDA WE DO KNOW THAT THE COST
FOR THE CW S. CARES PROJECT IN
THE COMPLETION DATE. HAVE NOT
BEEN UPDATED SINCE IT'S WHICH
pMONOLITHIC APPROACH TO THE
AGILE
THAT WAS REASONABLE WITH A NEW
WAY OF COMPLETING PROJECTS IN
THE STATE NEEDED TO ADJUST TO
THAT BUT NOW IT'S BEEN A COUPLE
OF YEARS SINCE THAT TRANSITION.
IN MAY MAKE SENSE TO ASK FOR
ADDITIONAL GUIDANCE ON WHAT THE
TRUE COST MIGHT BE. FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
NOW THAT WE HAVE A QUORUM IF I
MAY JUST TAKE A SECOND I'D LIKE
TO ESTABLISH IT.
DOCTOR ARAMBULA HERE HARPER
MATHIS RUBIO.
WOULD.
QUORUM.
IF I MAY VOMIT JUST TO ADD TO
THAT POINT WE ARE CURRENTLY
WORKING WITH AT THE DEPARTMENT
OF TECHNOLOGY AND THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE TO WORK ON A SPECIAL
PROJECT REPORT UPDATE.
THAT IS GOING TO INCLUDE A LOT
OF THE DETAILS SURROUNDING.
IMPROVEMENTS THAT ARE BEING MADE
ADDITIONAL PLANNING THAT NEEDS
TO TAKE PLACE IN TERMS OF
DEFINING.
WHAT IT IS THAT WE'RE BUILDING?
SO TAKING THE ITERATIVE
APPROACH.
WE DON'T WANT TO DO AS MUCH
PLANNING AND DIFF DEFINITION OF
REQUIREMENTS AS THERE IS WHEN
YOU'RE TRYING TO BUILD
EVERYTHING IN ONE SINGLE BIG
BANG.
BUT WHAT WE HAVE TO DO IS WE
HAVE TO BE ABLE TO DESCRIBE WHEN
WE'RE GOING TO BE DONE.
AND WHEN ARE WE GOING TO HAVE A
MINIMUM VIABLE PRODUCT IN ORDER
TO BE ABLE TO SATISFY THE NEEDS
OF THE WORKERS.
SO WE'RE PUTTING SOME ADDITIONAL
EFFORT INTO PLANNING OF WHAT
THAT LOOKS LIKE SO THAT WE CAN.
HAVE YOU KNOW TRANSPARENCY IN
ACUTE AND I CONVERSATION ABOUT
WHAT PEOPLE CAN EXPECT.
AND WHEN SO WE'RE HAVE JUST
STARTED THAT PROCESS FOR THE S.
P. ARE WE PLAN ON HAVING IT.
SOMETIME THIS SUMMER MIDSUMMER.
IS THAT WHAT WE CURRENTLY HAVE
SCHEDULED SO THAT'S GOING TO BE
IN A VERY REVEALING IN TERMS OF
WHAT IT IS THAT WE'RE GOING TO
BE DOING GOING FORWARD. INTO THE
INTO THE BUDGET YEAR.
WILL NOT TAKE PUBLIC COMMENT ON
THE ISSUE ONE.
SEEING NONE ALL BRING UP TO THE
DYESS FOR ANY COMMENTS WE HAVE.
A FOLLOW UP ON THAT POINT IF I
CAN. IN LIGHT OF WANTING
TRANSPARENCY IN THAT
CONVERSATION IS THERE A POINT
WHERE WE CAN TALK ABOUT COST.
I'M HEARING TIMELINES BUT COST
IS AS IMPORTANT TO THIS
COMMITTEE AND I'M WONDERING IF
THERE'S AN UPDATE ON THE AGILE
APPROACH AND.
IF WE CAN EXPECT SOME COST
ESTIMATES
AND WHEN THOSE WOULD BECOMING.
SO WE WILL CERTAINLY HAVE A COST
UPDATE FOR IS PART OF THE MAY
REVISION WITH RESPECT TO BUDGET
YEAR. AND THEN THE DISCUSSIONS
THAT WERE CURRENTLY INVOLVED IN
WITH THE SPR ARE GOING INTO IT
LEND MORE TO. WHAT DOES THE
OVERALL PROJECT LOOK LIKE
AGAIN A LOT OF IT IS DEPENDENT
OF STILL ON PLANNING THAT NEEDS
TO OCCUR IN TERMS OF BUILDING
WHAT WE'RE CALLING IT PROJECT
BLUEPRINT? WHICH IS MORE OF WHAT
DO WE EXPECT TO BUILD AND WENT.
WITH THAT WE WILL HOLD ISSUE ONE
OPEN AND MOVE ON TO ISSUE TO
.
PERFECT THANK YOU WHAT THE
SEPARATELY ISSUE TOO I GET ALL
HAVE CHRISTINE DUDLEY TICKETS
THROUGH THE OVERVIEW.
WHAT'S GOING ON WITHIN THE
STATEWIDE AUTOMATED WELFARE
SYSTEM.
IT.
SO THERE ARE THREE CURRENTLY
SYSTEMS THAT.
PROVIDE THE AUTOMATION FOR
ELIGIBILITY DETERMINATION IN
CALIFORNIA THERE'S LRC POURING
CAO WIN. FOR SEVERAL YEARS NOW
WE'VE BEEN PLANNING TO.
MIGRATE ELLER AND SEE FOR INTO
A SINGLE SYSTEM.
HOWEVER OUR FEDERAL PARTNERS DID
NOT APPROVE OUR FUNDING REQUEST
FOR THAT MIGRATION. AND SO OUR
ACTIVITIES DID NOT BEGIN IN
JANUARY OF TWENTY EIGHTEEN AS WE
HAD ANTICIPATED. SO A CHANGE IN
DIRECTION JUST OCCURRED IN
DECEMBER AND WE HAVE NOT UPDATED
THE BUDGET YET THOSE CHANGES
WILL BE. COMPLETED IN THE MAY
REVISION PROCESS.
SO IT SEEMS THAT EPONA SUPPORT
ARE PHASED IMPLEMENTATION
APPROACH IN DOING THIS OVER
TIME.
BUT.
THEY WANTED MORE COMPREHENSIVE
PLANNING
AND SO ON THAT BASIS THEY HAVE
REQUIRED THE STATE COUNTIES TO
ENTER AN EXTENDED PLANNING
PHASE.
USING THIRD PARTY INDEPENDENT
CONSULTANTS TO HELP US.
DETERMINE THE APPROACH THE
REQUIREMENTS IN THE COST
ESTIMATES FOR ALL THE ACTIVITIES
NECESSARY TO IMPLEMENT A SINGLE
SYSTEM.
TO THAT END IN JANUARY THEY
APPROVED A REQUEST FOR FUNDING
FOR PLANNING. BUT AS WE BEGAN TO
DO THOSE PLANNING ACTIVITIES
THEY STILL BELIEVE WE WORK QUITE
REACHING.
THEIR GOAL OF COMPREHENSIVE
PLANNING FOR THE WHOLE SYSTEM SO
THEY ASKED US TO ACCELERATE SOME
OF OUR ACTIVITIES FOR THE COW
ONE ASSESSMENT AND TO EXTEND
THAT PLANNING PHASE.
WE HAVE.
DONE THAT AND ON MARCH
THIRTIETH WE SUBMITTED A NEW
REQUEST FOR FEDERAL FUNDING FOR
THE PLANNING EFFORT. WE EXPECT
THEM TO COMPLETE THEIR REVIEW OF
THAT THIS WEEK WE HAVE WORKED
VERY CLOSELY WITH THEM THEY KNEW
WHAT WE WERE GOING TO SUBMIT
BEFORE WE DID.
AND ACTUALLY WE'VE BEGUN AS MUCH
OF THAT WORK AS WE CAN BECAUSE
THE TIME LINES ARE SO SHORT.
THE TIMELINE THAT WAS IN YOUR
SUBCOMMITTEE AGENDA WAS
DEVELOPED OVER A YEAR AGO WITH
THIS EXTENDED PLANNING THERE ARE
NUMBER OF THOSE FACES. THAT WE
HAVE SHADED TO SHOW YOU WHAT WE
ARE CURRENTLY ANALYZING THE LRC
FOR MIGRATION THE LONG TERM AND
A NO CONSOLIDATED PORTAL ALL OF
THOSE THINGS ARE WITHIN THIS
PLAN.
PHASE.
SO THE MAJORITY OF THE PLANNING
AND ANALYSIS ACTIVITIES WILL BE
COMPLETED THIS SUMMER AND WILL
RESULT IN THE DEVELOPMENT
IMPLEMENTATION STRATEGY AND
UPDATED TIMELINE. AND NEW COST
ESTIMATES
THAT WE WILL INCLUDE IN THE
PROJECT APPROVAL DOCUMENTS THAT
WE WILL SUBMIT IN THE NOVEMBER.
I KEPT IT CURRENT PLAN IS TO
BEGIN THE FIRST PHASE OF DESIGN
AND DEVELOPMENT IN JANUARY
TWENTY NINETEEN.
NEXT WE HAVE MISTER BLUNT.
I THANK YOU AGAIN NOT TAUGHT
PLAN DEPUTY DIRECTOR AT CDSS ON
CONCUR WITH ON THIS DUDLEY'S A
DESCRIPTION OF THE OVERALL
APPROACH TO THE.
CREATION THE CALCITE SYSTEM HOW
ARE BUDGET WILL ESSENTIALLY BE
UPDATED MADE TO REFLECT THIS
MORE INTENSIVE PLANNING PROCESS
OF REALLY NOTHING TO ADD THEIR.
I CAN'T SPEAK TO THE ISSUE
AROUND STAKEHOLDER INVOLVEMENT
IF YOU WOULD LIKE AT THIS TIME
OR WHETHER YOU WANT TO MISTER
HALE TO PRESENT ON THAT FIRST I
THINK MR HELD IS PRESENTING
NEXT.
TO.
BIRTH.
WE MAKE A SPOT FUHRMAN YEAH
VOTE.
FOR FIFTY.
SPICY.
I'M IS CHAIR OF MY CARE WITH
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY I'M ALSO HERE THOUGH ON
BEHALF OF OTHER ADVOCATES FOSTER
CARE ADVOCATES LEGAL SERVICE
ADVOCATES.
AM SOME OF CAN FOLKS IN THE
FOOD POLICY COMMUNITY SOME OR
ALL OF THIS FOR REQUESTING A
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE TO
ESTABLISH A STAKEHOLDER WORKING
GROUP. TO ADVISE THE
ADMINISTRATION AND COUNTIES ON
THE SYSTEM MIGRATION AS IT GOES
FOR.
WE THINK THIS IS AN EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT.
ENDEAVOR THAT THE STATE IS
INVOLVED IN RIGHT NOW ONE THAT'S
GOING TO HAVE SIGNIFICANT.
POTENTIALLY EXTREMELY POSITIVE
IMPACTS FOR CLIENTS.
AND THAT IS I THINK IT THE
CENTER OF WHY WE'RE REQUESTING
THE TBL IS BECAUSE WE DO THINK
THAT HAVING THE VOICES OF
CLIENTS AND PEOPLE WHO HAVE
SIGNIFICANT EXPERIENCE. AND HOW
THE SYSTEMS WORK ON THE GROUND
AND HOW THEY WERE AND HOW OUR
CLIENTS INTERFACE INTERACT WITH
THEM.
IS IS GOING TO MAKE THAT.
THAT MIGRATION THAT MUCH MORE
EFFECTIVE WHEN IT COMES OUT.
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT ARE
ADVOCATES HAVE BEEN INVOLVED
WITH IN A VARIETY OF PROJECTS
OVER MANY YEARS PROBABLY MOST
NOTABLY THE WORK AROUND THE
AFFORDABLE CARE ACT. AND THAT'S
VERY STAKEHOLDER WORK GROUPS
THAT WERE ESTABLISHED THERE
WHICH I THINK IN RETROSPECT
REALLY QUITE BENEFICIAL TO THE
PROCESS TO ENSURE THAT WE HAVE
TO KIND OF ROLL OUT THAT WE DID
FOR THAT.
SO WE'D WE BRING NOT JUST
EXPERIENCE OUR CLIENTS BUT I
THINK WE ALSO CAN BRING THE
EXPERIENCE OF.
WORKING IN IT SYSTEMS TO THIS
PROCESS QUITE EFFECTIVELY ARM
AND I THINK AT THE BOTTOM WHAT
WE'RE REALLY HOPING HERE IS THAT
WE CAN MAKE THE SYSTEM WORK
BETTER. THAT THERE WILL BE LESS
CLIMB AIRS FASTER OPERATIONS.
PROVISION OF BENEFITS OR
CLIENTS.
AND ENSURING THAT REALLY VOTE
THAT THE CLIENTS GET WHAT THIS
BODY.
HAS CREATED FOR THEM AND THAT
THEY GET IT IN A TIMELY FASHION.
WITHOUT AIR SO FOR ALL THOSE
REASONS WE ARE REQUESTING A
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE THAT
WOULD.
ESTABLISH SUCH A STATE WORKER
PROCESS DURING AUDIT THE
IMPLEMENTATION AND THE
MIGRATION.
THANK YOU MISTER HELD.
NEXT WE HAVE ANDREW SHANE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
VIRGINIA CHAIN.
HERE TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE
LIGHTS OF TRANSFORM CALL FRESH
I'M A GROUP OF THE FOOD POLICY
ADVOCATES I THINK MY COVERED
MOST OF IT BUT JUST COME TO PUT
POINTS OF WHY WERE IN SUPPORT OF
THIS ACTIVITY PROCESS.
TO THE POINT OF OF OF ADDING
VALUE.
YOU KNOW I THINK IT'S OUR OUR
VIEW AND THINK IT'S BEEN BORNE
OUT ANOTHER.
PROJECTS INCLUDING THE DOUBLING
OF OF EBT THAT I'M A SPOKEN TO
PREVIOUSLY THAT BY HAVING
ADVOCATES EVEN CLIENTS
THEMSELVES OF YOUR ENDEAVOR TO
THE FUNDRAISER ON OUR OWN AND
ACTUALLY BRING THAT ON THE
GROUND PERSPECTIVE. ON THAT EVEN
THOUGH THEY OR WE MIGHT NOT HAVE
TECHNICAL EXPERTISE IN IN EVERY
AREA THAT HAVING THAT
PERSPECTIVE INFORMS THE PROCESS.
AND AND THAT NOT JUST AT THE AT
THAT AT THE END IN TERMS OF USE
USER TESTING AND THAT REALLY TO
START THAT SOON AND WE
UNDERSTAND THAT THE BUT STILL A
PLANNING PROCESS RIGHT NOW BUT
THAT'S OVER COMING FORWARD NOW
TO HAVE THINGS IN. IN IN
PREPARATION FOR FOR WHEN
ACTIVITIES MOVE FROM PLANNING TO
TO EXECUTION.
AND SECONDLY I THINK OUR
PERSPECTIVE ON IS THAT THE
POLICY SHOULD DRIVE THE
TECHNOLOGY.
AND SO WERE WERE HOPING THAT
THIS IS AN OPPORTUNITY AS MIKE
SAID NOT JUST TO BE MANY GETTING
ERRORS ON BUT TO BE REALLY
LIFTING IT UP AS A MOMENT TO
ACHIEVE. EXCELLENCE AND AND
ACCOUNTABILITY IN THE PROCESS
AND I JUST WANNA SAY THANK YOU
TO BOTH THE STATE AND THE
COUNTIES IN A MISTER MAC IS HERE
AS WELL WE'VE ALREADY HAD VERY
PRODUCTIVE MEETINGS THEM AND
TURN OF TOUCH IT WITH THIS GUY
LOOK LIKE. THANK YOU.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
HELLO.
CAPITAL AND YEAH I'M.
FIRST COLLEGES I SAY THAT WE WE
WE AGREE WITH THE STAKEHOLDERS
THAT THERE NEEDS TO BE GREATER
STAKEHOLDER INVOLVEMENT IN IN
THE COUNCILS.
PLANNING PROCESS I'D LIKE TO
MAKE A FEW POINTS ABOUT THAT ON.
ONE POINT TO MAKE IS UNLIKE.
AB TWELVE NINETY SIX AND CAL
HERE'S THAT WAS A START FROM
SCRATCH PROCESS WHAT WERE
UNDERTAKING HERE IS ESSENTIALLY
LOOKING AT THREE SYSTEMS THAT WE
HAVE NOW AND THE FUNCTIONALITY
WITHIN THOSE THREE SYSTEMS AND
COMBINING THEM INTO ONE UNIFIED
COUNCIL SYSTEM SO. IN A LOT OF
WAYS THE REQUIREMENTS AND
FUNCTIONALITY.
IT IS ALREADY IS ALREADY THERE
WE'RE NOT WE'RE NOT WE'RE NOT
THINKING IN THE SO IN TERMS OF
NEW FUNCTIONALITY IN TERMS OF
UTILIZING THE FUNCTIONALITY
HAVE.
THAT SAID ON.
HERE HERE'S WHAT HERE'S WHAT WE
WOULD PROPOSE AYE IT IN RESPONSE
TO THE NEED ARM FIRST.
.
WE BELIEVE THERE NEEDS TO BE
ARMED WITH STAKEHOLDERS ARE A
MAJOR LEVEL SAT ON THIS A MAJOR
LEVEL SET MEETING PROBABLY THIS
SUMMER.
.
MIGHT BE TWO MEETINGS MIGHT EVEN
INCLUDE A DEMO OF THE EXISTING
LR A SYSTEM WHICH IS WHAT SORRY
LEADER REPLACEMENT SYSTEM WHICH
IS THE SYSTEM THAT THE FEDS ARE
SENSUALLY THANK. TRIED TO USE
THAT AS BEST YOU CAN AS YOU GO
FORWARD INTO THE SINGLE SAUCE.
.
WE WOULD TRY TO DO THAT THIS
SUMMER
FOLLOWING THAT WE BELIEVE
THERE'S A NEED FOR PERIODIC
BONTA CONTINUED MEETINGS WAS
STAKEHOLDERS ARE ABOUT THAT
ABOUT. THE PROCESS AND WHERE WE
ARE IN IT AND THOSE WOULD GO ON
FOR SEVERAL YEARS ARE THAT THE
PACE OF THOSE MEETINGS IN THE
FREQUENCY WOULD DEPEND ON KIND
OF WHERE WE ARE IN THE PROJECT.
AND THEN THIRD I THINK THERE
NEEDS TO BE A FORMAL ROLE FOR
ADVOCATES AND FOR CLIENTS IN THE
USER AREN'T YOU KNOW CLIENT
FACING PIECES OF THE SAW SYSTEM
NOT ALL OF IT IS QUITE FACING
BUT SOME THAT ARE. ARMED AND WE
WOULD WANT DEFINITELY WANT
CLIENT IN PUT THAT IN THAT NEEDS
TO BE A FORMALIZED ROLE.
IT NEEDS TO BE SUBJECT TO THE
THE THE CONDITION AND SORT OF
WORK AROUND THE ISSUE OF WE ARE
IN A IN A PROCUREMENT
ENVIRONMENT AND SOME THINGS NEED
TO BE KEPT CONFIDENTIAL BUT
WE'VE BEEN ABLE HOW SUCCESSFUL
STAKEHOLDER INPUT IN THE PAST
AND WE WELL. ON-AGAIN ON A
ADVOCATES AND THE LEGISLATURE
INTERESTED ARE ON CSS WOULD BE
HAPPY TO PROVIDE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE IN THE FORM OF A OF A
FIRST DRAFT OF THE.
TRAILER BILL ALONG THESE LINES.
THANK YOU IN THE FORM OF TI.
WE WILL NOW TAKE PUBLIC COMMENT
ON THE ISSUE TO.
YEAH KEVIN AS THE COALITION
CALIFORNIA WELFARE RIGHTS
ORGANIZATION.
THIS COMPUTER SYSTEM THAT DESIGN
PUT THE BENEFICIARIES OF THE
PROGRAM.
AND THE BENEFITS WE SHOULD BE
INVOLVED IN THE PROCESS FROM
EIGHT TO VINNIE.
AND WORK WITH JOURNEY THIS TWO
WAYS THAT WE HAVE INPUT ONE IS.
BECOME THEY SAY HERE'S THE
CONCLUSION WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT
THE CONCLUSION.
BUT BY LOOKING AT THE CONCLUSION
WE HAVE NO IDEA WHAT COMES WHAT
WHAT THE CONSIDERATIONS THAT
THEY TOOK AND TOOK YOU HURT THAT
THEY LOOKED OUT BEFORE THEY CAME
UP WITH THE CONCLUSION.
SO WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
ARE NOT ONLY LOOKING AT THE
CONCLUSION. BUT ALSO INVOLVED
THE CONSIDERATIONS
AND THERE ARE THREE DIFFERENT
SYSTEMS
AND THEY'RE LOOKING IN SOME OF
THEM ARE INCOMPATIBLE.
SO THEIR HOPE THAT THE HOPE MUCH
OF CONSIDERATIONS IT WOULD NEED
TO BE INVOLVED IN THAT TOO WE'RE
ONE OF. DOG AND PONY SHOW WE ONE
OF REAL MEANINGFUL
PARTICIPATION.
REFORM THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON SELENA PRIOR WITH
A CI YOU I'M WE ARE SUPPORTIVE
OF THIS PROPOSAL WE WAS WE WOULD
LIKE TO MAKE SURE THAT OUR
SOCIAL WORKERS ARE INCLUDED
SINCE THEY'RE THE ONES THAT ARE
IMPACTED THEN THEY CAN TELL YOU
WHAT THE CHALLENGES OF THE
BENEFITS OF THE SYSTEMS I. THINK
YOU THINK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON KATIE ENTER
CHILDREN NOW WERE IN FULL
SUPPORT OF THE ADVOCACY
PROPOSAL
GIVE THINK HUMAN.
FRANK BACK WITH THE COUNTY
WELFARE DIRECTORS WERE UP ALONG
WITH THE STATE PARTNERS BRINGING
THOSE SYSTEMS. FOR THE BENEFIT
OF THE CLIENTS AND.
WE AGREE WITH THE ADVOCATES
INTEREST AND PARTICIPATION WITH
FAR TO BEING PART OF THE
CONVERSATIONS.
SIR.
SEEING NO FURTHER PUBLIC COMMENT
I'LL BRING IT UP TO THE DYESS.
WANTED TO ASK A QUESTION OF
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES IF
YOU THOUGHT THERE WAS ANY COSTS
ASSOCIATED. WITH THE STAKEHOLDER
PROPOSAL.
RIGHT I WOULDN'T THINK SO AT
THIS POINT BUT WILL LOVE WILL
ASK OUR OSI PARTNERS I I DON'T
THINK PROVIDING A DEMO OR THOSE
THINGS. ON CDSS ON.
IT HAS A LONG HISTORY OF OF
RUNNING EXPECTED STAKEHOLDER
STAKEHOLDER INVOLVEMENT.
SO IN MY EXPERIENCE NEARLY WITH
MY IT'S MY EXPENSIVE PRIOR STATE
COURTS CONVERSATIONS USUALLY WE
DO THIS WITH EXISTING RESOURCES
SO I DON'T ANTICIPATE ANYTHING
BUT. IT'S AT THE DIVIDE IT ALL
DEPENDS ON HOW COMPLEX THIS.
WELL I'D LIKE TO ASK THE
ADVOCATES THEN IN LIGHT OF THAT
TO WORK WITH THE ADMINISTRATION
AND FINANCE ON DRAFT TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE TO SUBMIT TO US
BEFORE MAY FOURTH.
SO THAT WE CAN CONSIDER IT FOR
POTENTIAL ADOPTION AT THE MAY
REVISION.
WITH THAT WE WILL HOLD ISSUE TO
OPEN IN THE BOND ISSUE THREE
PER.
I AM.
I CAN THINK.
CAPTION.
GOOD AFTERNOON.
SWORD BE HAPPY TO I'M CHEMICALLY
WAIT CAL FRESH PRINCE SHIP WITH
MY COLLEAGUE KIM JOHNSON CAL
WORKS BRANCH CHIEF. AND WE'RE
HERE TO PROVIDE A BRIEF UPDATE
ON A NEW PROJECT THE DEPARTMENT
HAS UNDERTAKEN. AND PARTNERSHIP
WITH STAKEHOLDERS OUT WHICH
REALLY FRANKLY IS TO LOOK AT
IMPROVING OUR PROCESS AND ARE
ACCESS IN OUR SERVICE TO OUR
CUSTOMERS. WHEN YOU APPLY FOR
CAL PRESSURE CHO WORKS YOU CAN
DO THREE THINGS APPLIED
INTERVIEW AND AND SMITH LA
VERIFICATIONS GET VERIFIED.
AND WE HAVE TAKEN A LOT OF STEPS
OVER THE PAST FEW YEARS TO
IMPROVE THE APPLICATION PROCESS.
AND THE INTERVIEW PROCESS AND
NOW WE WANT TACKLE THE
VERIFICATION PROCESS.
SO WE HAVE.
DETER OUR P. AND ENGAGED A
CONSULTANT WITH EXISTING FUNDS
THAT WE HAD CALLED SOCIAL
INTEREST SOLUTIONS WHO IS NOW
ENGAGED IN A PROJECT.
POD TO PRINT TO DO THREE THINGS
ONE ASSESS OUR CURRENT
VERIFICATION.
SITUATION AS WELL AS OTHER
STATES OF COURSE THE FEDERAL HUB
FOR MEDI CAL. TO ENGAGE
STAKEHOLDERS.
PARTICULARLY COUNTIES IN
CLIENTS BUT EXPERTS FROM AROUND
THE COUNTRY A WE JUST HAD A
WONDERFUL ALL DAY SITE VISIT
SACRAMENTO COUNTY ON FRIDAY TO
REALLY SEE. I GET UNDER THE HOOD
IF YOU WELL AND SEE HOW THE
SYSTEM WORKS AND THREE PRODUCED
A ROADMAP WITH A SET OF SHORT
MEDIUM AND LONG TERM OPTIONS
CONSIDERATIONS RECOMMENDATIONS
FOR HOW TO MODERNIZE IMPROVE OUR
VERIFICATION PROCESS. SO THAT WE
IMPROVE ACCESS AND ACCURACY AND
SPEED HOPEFULLY TO.
BOB THERE'S A PROJECT WEBSITE
THAT HAS ALL THE INFORMATION
INCLUDING THE KICKOFF WEAPON ARE
AND MONTHLY UPDATES ARE POSTED
AND WE HOPE TO BE COMING BACK
WITH US WE WILL BE COMING BACK
WITH A MID PERIOD UPDATE AROUND
JUNE. AND THEN A FINAL PROJECT
REPORT AT THE END OF THE SUMMER.
THANK YOU.
MR JOHNSON IF ANYTHING
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE HELLO.
YEAH WE WERE FINE SO WE DON'T
HAVE ANY FUNDING.
FOR THIS PURPOSE THIS IS BOBBY
NUMBER.
ISSUE RESOURCES AT THE.
WE WILL NOW TAKE PUBLIC COMMENT
ON ISSUE THREE.
ANDERSON CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF FOOD BANKS I JUST WANT TO
THANK THE DEPARTMENT FOR HAVING
A VERY OPEN PROCESS WAS
STAKEHOLDER ENGAGEMENT.
AND JUST TO NOTE THAT THE FIRST
A MEETING OF STAKEHOLDER.
INPUT RAN SO LONG THAT ALL
ISSUES CAN BE ADDRESSED AT THE
SIGNS OF THE INTEREST IN IN THIS
TOPIC BUT AGAIN THANKS FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY AND OTHERS WERE MORE
FOLLOW UP BUT JUST TO PUT A MARK
ON THAT THANK YOU.
A MICROWAVE WESTERN CENTER LAW
POVERTY.
WE'D LIKE TO SUSTAIN HERSELF TO
THE COMMENTS OF THE FOOD BANKS
FROM THIS IS A VERY IMPORTANT
EVER ONE THAT WE PLAN ON
SPENDING A LOT OF TIME ON. AND
SOMETHING THAT I THINK COULD
HAVE SIGNIFICANT AGAIN IMPACTS
POSITIVELY FOR OUR CLIENTS THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SIR.
SEEING NO FURTHER PUBLIC COMMENT
OR BRING IT UP TO THE DYESS AND
I'D LIKE TO ASK THE DEPARTMENT
IF I CAN.
IT SEEMS THAT THE WHOLE PROJECT
IS WORKING TOWARDS A REAL
FRAMEWORK FOR IMPROVING
ELIGIBILITY AND APPLICATION. AND
I'M WONDERING WHAT THERE BE ANY
ISSUE ON FORMALIZING THE MISSION
AND VALUES BEHIND THIS ANY THERE
SR AL OR POTENTIALLY BEEN
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE WE WELCOME
THAT PARTNERSHIP.
WITH THAT I'D LIKE TO THE.
BUT.
MEET SINCE IT'S OUR DUTY TO FOR
ACCOUNTABILITY PURPOSES IF WE
CAN BE MORE ENGAGED AND INFORMED
ABOUT WHAT THE. PROGRESS OR
WHATEVER IT IS THAT YOU GUYS ARE
DOING SO THAT WE CAN STAND UP OF
IT AND REALLY APPRECIATE THAT.
WITHOUT I'D LIKE TO ASK THE
ALEJO FOR.
YOUR ASSISTANCE IN WORKING WITH
OUR STAFF AS WELL AS IN
COLLABORATION WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION SO THAT WE CAN
CONSIDER A ADOPTING LANGUAGE IN
THE MAY REVISION.
THAT'S WHAT HAPPENED.
THANK YOU WITH THAT WE WILL HOLD
ISSUE THREE OPEN IN THE BOND
ISSUE FOR
.
OKAY GOOD AFTERNOON. MY NAME IS
CYNTHIA TALKER AND I'M A DEPUTY
DIRECTOR WITH THE OFFICE OF
SYSTEMS INTEGRATION. AND I AM
WITH.
WHEN NAY MAILLOT DEPUTY DIRECTOR
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES.
SO WE'RE HERE TO TALK ABOUT THE
METS MODERNIZATION BCP.
V. I. NARRATIVE IN THE AGENDA
WAS.
.
ON THE SPOT AND.
EXPLAINS THE PROPOSAL VERY WELL.
JUST TO SUMMARIZE WE ARE ASKING.
FOR SEVEN POINT NINE MILLION
EIGHT HUNDRED THOUSAND OF WHICH
IS GENERAL FUND.
FOR.
STAFF AND RESOURCES IN ORDER TO
IMPLEMENT.
ORGANS ARE TO MODERNIZE THE
HEALTH. INSURANCE SYSTEM WITH
INDIA H. YESES MATS.
SO IT'S A HIGH LEVEL REVIEW HOW.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE ILIO.
SO DANA WITH THE PART OF FINANCE
THIS PROJECT IS.
.
OF A WEEK WE GET WE RECEIVED THE
HANDS VERIFIEDBETS PROJECT BUT
MY UNDERSTANDING
SUCH A THE REASON WHY A LOT OF
THIS COST IS.
MOSTLY FEDERAL FUNDS.
GENERAL NOTE ABOUT IT PROJECT
DEVELOPMENT AND EARLIER IN THE
LIFE CYCLE OF THE PROJECT IS AN
OPPORTUNE TIME FOR THE
LEGISLATURE TO KNOW IF THEY HAVE
ANY PRIORITIES.
THIS COMMITTEE SEEMS TO INDICATE
SORT OF INTEREST IN EFFICIENCY
THAN THAT VERIFICATION THERE'S
OTHER.
PRIORITIES FOR THE LEGISLATURE
SUBMIT ATTENDANT TO NOTE THOUGH
THAT THEY CAN BE MORE EASILY FOR
THAT INTO THE DEVELOPMENT OF THE
PROJECT THANK YOU. WE WILL NOW
TAKE PUBLIC COMMENT ON ISSUE
FOR.
SEEING NONE I'LL BRING IT BACK
UP TO THE DYESS.
AS WE NOTED IN THE AGENDA WE'VE
BEEN THINKING ABOUT HOW MEDS
COULD FURTHER BE IMPROVED TO
ASSIST THE FILE CLEARANCE
PROCESS WITHIN CAL WORKS AND CAL
FRESH. WAS WONDERING IF YOU HAVE
ANY THOUGHTS ABOUT THIS.
WITH REGARDS TO THAT THE
CURRENT SCOPE OF THE CONTRA OF
THE MEDS MODERNIZATION IS TO GET
THE TECHNOLOGIES FROM NINETEEN
SEVENTIES TECHNOLOGY TO CURRENT.
AND TO REALLY FOCUS ON THAT TO
MAKE TO ENSURE.
CONTINUED STABILITY IT'S
ADVOCATES
CAPABILITY TO BE EXTENSIBLE FOR
FUTURE BUSINESS NEEDS OMICS
CENTER AND SO THE FOCUS OF IT IS
TO GET TO CURRENT TECHNOLOGY.
THERE'LL BE SOME INHERENT
BUSINESS BENEFITS
BUT THIS SPECIFICALLY IS NOT
PART OF SCOPE.
I'D LIKE TO ASK THE INFORMATION
THE ADMINISTRATION FOR THE
FOLLOWING INFORMATION THAT COULD
BE PROVIDED TO US IN WRITING TO
SUBCOMMITTEE STAFF.
AND OTHER INTERESTED LEGISLATIVE
STAFF AS WELL.
AND TO THE LA O. BEFORE MAY
FIRST IF POSSIBLE.
AND THESE ARE OUTLINED IN THE
STAFF COMMENT PORTION OF THE
AGENDA ITEMS SENATE'S THE THREE
QUESTIONS THAT WE ADDRESSED IF
POSS.
WITH THAT WE WILL HOLD ISSUE FOR
OPEN IN THE BOND ISSUE FIVE
.
GOOD AFTERNOON. MY NAME IS
ELAINE SKYROCKETS AND I'M THE
ASSISTANT DIRECTOR WITH THE
CALIFORNIA OFFICE OF HEALTH
INFORMATION INTEGRITY WITHIN
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
AGENCY.
I'M JUST BRIEFLY A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT FELLOW HIGH.
WE PROVIDE STATEWIDE LEADERSHIP
AND OVERSIGHT AND POLICY
FORMULATION DIRECTION OVERSIGHT
OF STATE DEPARTMENTS WHO ARE.
EITHER HIP OF BUSINESS
ASSOCIATES ARE COVERED ENTITIES.
ARM AM WE WHAT WE DO WITH IS WE.
WE ESTABLISH AN UPDATE POLICY WE
MONITOR STATE AND FEDERAL
LEGISLATION ACTIONS WE CONDUCT
COMPLIANCE REVIEWS AND TAKE A
LOOK HOW THE DEPARTMENTS ARE
DOING.
AND WE PROVIDE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE WHERE NEEDED.
I REQUEST TODAY IS TO
PERMANENTLY ESTABLISH A STAFF
SERVICES MANAGER ONE POSITION
WHICH IS CURRENTLY LIMITED TERM
EXPIRES IN JUNE JUNE THIRTIETH
THE SHARE.
NOW THIS AYE. POSITION PLAYS A
VERY IMPORTANT ROLE IN A VERY
SMALL OFFICE ON JUST REAL
BRIEFLY TO TELL YOU WHAT THE
POSITION IS DOING. BY THE HAND
ALL OF OUR ADMINISTRATIVE
MATTERS THINGS LIKE GOD COMPLY
CONTRACTING AND PROCUREMENT
PERSONNEL ACCOUNTING THAT PAY
THE BILLS.
I'M BUT THEY ALSO ON THE
PROGRAMMATIC SIDE THEY MANAGE
OUR FEDERAL AND STATE
LEGISLATIVE ACTIVITY SO WE
MONITOR ALL FEDERAL LEGISLATION
RELATED TO PRIVACY AND SECURITY
IN HAVE OBVIOUSLY. AND RELATED
STATE LAWS WELL.
THE POSITION ALSO MONITORS THE
OFFICE OF CIVIL CIVIL RIGHTS FOR
ANY INVESTIGATION WORK THEY'RE
DOING SO WE'RE MONITORING TRENDS
AND HAVE A VIOLATIONS.
A AND THEY ALSO UPDATE OUR STATE
HEALTH INFORMATION POLICY MANUAL
WHICH IS A SYNTHESIS OF ALL THE
STATE AND FEDERAL LAWS RELATED
TO HIPAA. AND PRIVACY AND
SECURITY AND IT'S A DOMINO
EFFECT AND THEN THAT PERSON IS
ALSO UPDATING OUR COMPLIANCE
TOOLS AS LEGISLATION HAS AN
IMPACT ON THOSE DIFFERENT TOOLS
WE USE OUR COMPLIANCE PROGRAM.
AND THEN FINALLY THEY ALSO
CONDUCT OUR STATEWIDE HIP AND T.
ASSESSMENT GIVES US OUR BASELINE
OF WHO ALL THE STATE DEPARTMENTS
ARE THAT ARE COVERED ARE
IMPACTED IN SOME WAY BY HIPPA.
THAT'S VERY ROBUST EIGHTEEN
MONTH PROCESS AND WE GO OUT TO A
THIS JUST IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN
ONE OUNCE OF THREE HUNDRED
SEVENTY ONE DEPARTMENTS. SUCH
ASSESSING WHO'S IMPACTED SUCH A
BRIEF OVERVIEW OF WHAT. THE
POSITION IS DOING A HUMAN.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE ILIO ANY
COMMENTS ON ISSUE FIVE.
AT LEAST FOR OUR DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE WE SUPPORT THE REQUEST
FOR THE REASONS STATED BY THE
OFFICE
THANK YOU.
WE WILL NOT TAKE PUBLIC COMMENTS
ON ISSUE FIVE.
MISTER CHAIR IF YOU MIGHT AT
LIKE TO DEFECT COMING UP ABOUT
ISSUE FOR.
WITH RESPECT TO THE MEDS FILE
CLEARANCE PROCESS.
WE UNDERSTAND THAT SORT OF
WITHIN SCOPE.
I'M IS A FLUID CONSIDERATION AND
THAT THERE'S A LOT TO BE DONE TO
BRING MADS.
UP TO AT THE MODERN STATE BUT.
THE FILE CLEARANCE PROCESS IS
SORT OF AT THE HEART OF ONE OF
THE REASONS WE HAVE MET ITS.
A PROCESS BY WHICH COUNTY
WORKERS IDENTIFY.
WHO'S WHO'S APPLYING IT TO MAKE
SURE ARM THAT THE APPLICANT IS
NOT SOMEWHERE ELSE IN THE SYSTEM
DOESN'T HAVE A CASE OPEN. IS WHO
THERE WHO ARE SAYING THEY ARE
RIGHT NOW IT'S A VERY INTENSIVE
PROCESS THAT ALL COUNTIES
UNDERTAKE AND IT IS LABOR
INTENSIVE AND TO THE EXTENT
THAT.
BY MODERNIZING THE METS PROGRAM
CAN CREATE AUTOMATED
EFFICIENCIES TO THE WAY WE DO
THAT WE COULD BE MORE EFFICIENT
AND MORE EFFECTIVE. ARM AND AND
FREE UP STAFF TIME FOR OTHER
VITAL FUNCTIONS SO WE WOULD
ENCOURAGE THE ADMINISTRATION
UNDERSTANDING THERE ARE ALWAYS
CONSTRAINTS. TO SEE IF THEY
COULD WORK THAT ON INTO THE
SCOPE AS THEY MOVE FORWARD.
THE CONCERNED.
COMMENTS ARE WELL APPRECIATED.
SCENE KNOW. ABOUT FURTHER PUBLIC
COMMENT ON ISSUE FIVE WILL BRING
IT UP TO THE DYESS.
SEEING NO COMMENTS FROM US WILL
HOLD ISSUE FIVE OPEN A MOVE ON
ISSUE SIX
THANK YOU
.
GOOD AFTERNOON. GRIFFIN WEDDINGS
JOHN ROWLAND NAM A SPECIAL
CONSULTANT FOR THE OFFICE OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT SUPPORT AND I'M
WITH.
AND I'M CRISTINA ALAN AND I AM
AN ASSISTANT CHIEF COUNSEL FOR
THE OFFICE OF LAW ENFORCEMENT'S
PART.
SO HERE TO TALK ABOUT OUR BUDGET
CHANGE PROPOSAL YEAH IT'S
THERE'S TWO PARTS TO A BUDGET
CHANGE PROPOSAL.
BUT WE ARE LOOKING TO RECLASSIFY
SOME POSITIONS INVESTIGATOR
POSITIONS TO A SPECIAL AGENT.
AND CHRISTINE IS GONNA TALK
ABOUT IN THE TOURNEY FOR
POSITION THAT WE ARE SUCCEEDING
IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY.
.
WE'RE CURRENTLY DOING WITH
RECRUITMENT RETENTION PROBLEM.
WITH OUR INVESTIGATORS BECAUSE
OF THEIR CLASSIFICATION.
WE'RE REQUESTING TO RECLASSIFY
SEVEN INVESTIGATOR POSITIONS TO
SPECIAL AGENT.
AND TO SUPERVISE INVESTIGATOR
POSITIONS TO SENIOR SPECIAL
AGENT.
RIGHT NOW A OF THE NINE
POSITIONS WERE REQUESTING SEVEN
OF THOSE NINE OR FILL BY RETIRED
ANNUITANTS.
WHICH IS A IT'S PROBLEMATIC
FROM THE PERSPECTIVE.
THAT THERE'S LIMITATIONS ON THE
NUMBER OF HOURS THEY CAN WORK.
WE ONLY HAVE TWO FULL TIME
INVESTIGATORS AT THIS POINT IN
TIME.
AND PITCHERS INTERESTINGLY
ENOUGH THE RETIREMENT NOTICE
THAT WE'RE.
THAT WERE UTILIZING ARE ALL
FORMER SPECIAL AGENTS WHICH IS
THE POSITION THAT WE'RE SEEKING
SO WE CANNOT KNOW WHAT WE'RE
GETTING IN REGARDS TO THEIR
THEIR QUALIFICATIONS.
FOR PROBLEM RIGHT NOW IT'S A
WORD A CATCH TWENTY TWO
SITUATION.
BECAUSE OF POST PEACE OFFICER
STANDARDS AND TRAINING.
UP RIGHT NOW INVESTIGATORS MUST
GO THROUGH A SIX MONTH ACADEMY
PRIOR TO WORKING FOR ALMOST A
SIX MONTH POST ACADEMY.
YET POST IS DENIED A REQUEST
BECOME A POST ABC BECAUSE WE DO
NOT MEET THEIR QUALIFICATIONS
BUT DO NOT MEET THE CRITERIA
THEY SENT US A LETTER. IN
SEPTEMBER OF TWENTY SEVENTEEN
BASICALLY STATING THAT. YOU DO
NOT DO THE FULL RANGE OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT RESPONSIBILITIES.
BICU DO NOT DO GENERAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT.
WE ARE ESSENTIALLY IN INTERWAR
OR A HYBRID WERE UNIQUE IN THAT
WE'RE WE ARE AN INTERNAL AFFAIRS
UNIT ATTACHED TO AN OVERSIGHT
ENTITY WERE NOT ATTACHED TO A
POLICE DEPARTMENT OR SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENT OF HIGHWAY PATROL.
SO WE DON'T MEET THE POST
CRITERIA SO. WERE BETWEEN A ROCK
AND A HARD PLACE BECAUSE WE HAVE
TO HIRE PEOPLE THAT HAVE A POST
ACADEMY AS A CLASSIFICATION
REQUIRES. BUT WE CAN DO NOTHING
TO.
ADVANCE OR CONTINUE THEIR POST
CERTIFICATION THERE'S TRAINING
THAT GUY COMES ALONG WITH THAT
WE DON'T HAVE THE ABILITY TO DO
IT BECAUSE POST IS NOT CERTIFIED
US. AS OPPOSED AGENCY.
ARE AND THAT'S WHAT THIS IS THIS
HAS CREATED A RECRUITMENT
RETENTION ISSUE FOR US BECAUSE
THAT POST CERTIFICATION IS
CRITICAL TO PEACE OFFICERS.
BECAUSE IF THEY LOSE IT THEY
CAN'T GO WORK FOR ANOTHER
AGENCY.
SO WE'VE HAD A VERY TOUGH TIME.
FILLING THESE POSITIONS.
WE HAVE AS ICE IS I MENTIONED
WERE RELYING ON RETIRED
ANNUITANTS.
ONCE WE RECEIVED A LETTER FROM
POST.
WITH THE DENIAL WE RECOGNIZE WE
HAD A PROBLEM YOU KNOW FOR ITS
FORESTS AS SUSTAINABILITY.
CARTON.
SO WHAT WE DID WAS WE LOOKED AT
DIFFERENT CLASSIFICATIONS
AND AND THE CLASSIFICATION OF
SPECIAL AGENT REALLY SUITED THE
TYPES OF TYPE OF WORK THAT WE DO
WE ARE YOU DEAK IN THAT WE ONLY
CONDUCT INVESTIGATIONS.
UP PEACE OFFICERS FOR SERIOUS
MISCONDUCT FOR DEPARTMENTS TO
HOSPITALS AND DEVELOPMENT
SERVICES.
SO THERE'S A UNIQUE SKILL SET
THAT COMES WITH THAT.
YOU NEED TO HAVE WHAT YOU NEED
TO HAVE BEEN A SUPERVISOR YOU
NEED TO UNDERSTAND EMPLOYER
EMPLOYEE RELATIONSHIPS.
YOU NEED TO UNDERSTAND THE
PEACE OFFICERS BILL WRITES THE
INVESTIGATOR CLASSIFICATION THAT
WE CURRENTLY HAVE.
IS MORE OF A GENERAL
CLASSIFICATION THAT USE ACROSS
STATE SERVICES IT'S NOT SPECIFIC
TO WHAT WE DO IT'S NOT THAT THEY
CAN'T DO THAT INVESTIGATION BUT
WHAT WE FOUND EVEN. IN THE
POSITIONS WE FILLED IT'S ABOUT A
TWO YEAR PROCESS TO COME UP TO
SPEED.
THE PROBLEM IS IN THE MEANTIME
WE HAVE TO WE HAVE A CASELOAD.
IF THESE INVESTIGATIONS SO THAT
WE'RE DOING I THINK WE'VE DONE A
HUNDRED PEOPLE ALWAYS HAS BEEN
EXISTENCE FOR TWO YEARS.
WE'VE DONE IN THE FIRST TWO
YEARS MORE THAN A HUNDRED TWENTY
SIX INVESTIGATIONS DURING THAT
TIME.
SO IT'S IT'S A SIGNIFICANT CASE
LOAD IN. AND WHAT WE'RE FINDING
IS THAT THE SPECIAL AGENT IS A
BETTER CLASSIFICATION FOR THE
TYPE OF WORK THAT WE DO.
AND THEN.
LASTLY.
.
WE HAVE ANY ISSUE THAT THERE'S
A.
THERE'S A CONFLICT THAT'S
CREATED WE HAVE AN INVESTIGATOR
CONDUCTING AN INVESTIGATION. OF
ANOTHER INVESTIGATOR OR HOSPITAL
POLICE OFFICER THAT'S
REPRESENTED BY THE SAME
BARGAINING UNIT.
SO IT CREATES A CONFLICT IT'S
NOT THAT IT CAN'T HAPPEN OR IT
DOESN'T HAPPEN STATE SERVICE.
THE FACT REMAINS THAT IT'S NOT A
BEST PRACTICE.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE CHP OR YOU
LOOK IT DEPARTMENT ATTRACTIONS
THEY ALWAYS HAVE EXCLUDED
EMPLOYEES.
CONDUCTING INVESTIGATIONS TO
HELP AVOID THAT CONFLICT AND WE
HAVE DOCUMENTED INCIDENTS WHERE
WE'VE HAD CONFLICTS.
I DON'T SEE US.
ELLIOT'S BEEN OPPOSED TO THIS
AND THAT AND THEY HAVE STATED
HAY ACROSS.
YOU KNOW IT HAPPENS ACROSS.
.
STATE DEPARTMENTS.
IN TERMS OF OUR.
THIS CONFLICT BUT IT DOESN'T
MAKE IT RIGHT.
IT DOESN'T MAKE IT A BEST
PRACTICE AND THAT'S THAT'S
REALLY WHAT WE'RE ALL ABOUT WERE
FOCUSED ON BEST PRACTICES. FOR
THE POLICE DEPARTMENT SO
CERTAINLY.
WE HAVE TO HOLD DEPARTMENTS TO A
HIGHER STANDARD WE HAVE TO BE AT
A HIGHER STANDARD THAT'S WHAT
WE'RE SEEKING. THE RE
CLASSIFICATION OF THIS POSITION.
REALLY IT COMES DOWN TO
SUSTAINABILITY I THINK WE'VE
REALLY HAD A POSITIVE IMPACT ON
THE DEPARTMENTS.
UP TO THIS POINT TIME WE'RE
UNCOVERING THINGS THAT MAY HAVE
NOT BEEN UNCOVERED IN THE PAST
FOR MAKING RECOMMENDATIONS THE
DEPARTMENTS ARE MAKING
IMPROVEMENTS SO. OUR ROLE IS
IMPORTANT.
BUT TO CONTINUE TO SURVIVE
UTILIZING RETIRED ANNUITANTS IS
NOT A LONG TERM FIX FOR OUR
PROBLEMS.
SO WE JUST REQUEST YOUR SUPPORT
ON THAT PART OF OUR OUR BUDGET
PROPOSAL AND THEN HAVE CHRISTINE
TALK ABOUT OUR. ATTORNEY FOR
POSITION.
OKAY YES SO THE SECOND PART OF
OUR AND THE CP REQUEST IS FOR AN
ATTORNEY FOR OUR CENTRAL REGION.
AND THE REASONS FOR REQUEST FOR
TWO FULL THE THE FIRST
THE MAIN ONE IS BECAUSE I AM ARE
CENTRAL.
ESSENTIAL ATTORNEY CURRENTLY IT
AN ATTORNEY THREE. ASSEMBLY HAS
AN UNMANAGEABLE CASELOAD SHE HAS
THE LARGEST DEVELOPMENT CENTERS
WELL AS TUESDAY HOSPITALS. HAVE
VERSES ARE NORTH AND SOUTH
ATTORNEYS TO EACH CARRIED OUT
MOST ON WEDNESDAY HOSPITAL.
AND IN ADDITION JUST THE SHEER
NUMBERS OF THE CASES SHE CARRIES
NOT TOTALLY OVER DOUBLE THE
CASELOAD. AND ON TOP OF THE
CASELOAD NUMBERS THAT SHE ALSO
THE GEOGRAPHICALLY THE
FACILITIES ARE ALL EXTREMELY FAR
APART FROM EACH OTHER.
COMPARED TO OTHER REGIONS OF SHE
SPENDS A GREAT DEAL TIME
TRAVELING ON THE ROAD.
I SOARED TEMPORARY FIX AND FOR
NOW IT'S BEEN SORT OF LIKE OUR
PROBLEM THAT JAMAS EXPLAINING
THIS WEEK. I'M HIRED IN ARE A
INVESTIGATOR.
AND SO HE'S ABLE TO HELP WITH
SOME OF THE INTERVIEWS AND YOU
KNOW ATTENDING SOME OF THOSE BUT
HE'S NOT ABLE TO HELP WITH THE
LEGAL ASPECTS OF IT. IN HOPING
THAT HER THIRTIES MAKE
DETERMINATIONS ON A PLATE
DISCIPLINE AND. YOU KNOW MAKING
RECOMMENDATIONS AND. MONITORING
THE. APPELLATE PROCESS THAT GOES
ON AND THE DECISION DDS
ATTORNEYS.
SO AND WE NEED WE NEED SOMEBODY
IN CENTRAL TO UP HELP CARRY PART
OF THAT CASE LOAD. AND THE
REASON OR REQUESTING A FOUR IS
BECAUSE OFTENTIMES ARE ATTORNEYS
ARE MONITORING AND. REPORTING ON
ATTORNEY FORCE FOR DTS HD DTS.
AND SO IT IT JUST DOESN'T MAKE
SENSE HAVE A THREE.
YOU KNOW MAKING RECOMMENDATIONS
TO FOR WHOM HE HAS MORE
EXPERIENCE THAT IT'S BETTER TO
HAVE A FOR MONITORING FOR. SO
AND.
THOSE THE TWO PRIMARY REQUEST WE
ALSO LOST TO I'M ALLERGIC
CONTRACT ATTORNEYS
UP LAST YEAR SO THAT THEY WERE
ABLE TO HELP BEFORE WERE IN
OBVIOUSLY WORKING MORE DOWN
SOME.
MANPOWER THERE.
SO VOTER QUESTION ATTORNEY FOR
FOR THOSE REASONS THANK YOU.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE ELLIOTT.
ANY PUBLIC COMMENT ON ISSUE FIVE
AT THIS TIME.
TO ME ISSUE SIX.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MACHINE LEVINE
ON BEHALF OF CS ONLY A WHICH IS
BARGAINING UNIT SEVEN.
WE WOULD BE LOSING NINE
POSITIONS AS A RESULT THIS
REQUEST VACATION WE ARE OPPOSED
TO IT.
WE WOULD PUT ON THE RECORD THAT.
OF IT WAS UNTIL ABOUT A COUPLE
MONTHS AGO THAT WE FIRST FOUND
OUT ABOUT THIS ON THE WERE NO
CONVERSATIONS WERE HAPPY TO WORK
WITH THEM TO CHIEF POST AGENCY
STATUS.
A WERE UNAWARE.
THAT THERE WERE ISSUES AROUND
GETTING POSE CERTIFICATION.
THAT ALSO LOOKS ARTIST WIENER.
ALSO STIPULATE THAT THE.
AS FAR AS A CONFLICT IS
CONCERNED IT'S NOT UNIQUE OR
SOMEHOW A PECULIAR A RARE THAT
AN AGENCY.
HAS AYE A BUILT INTO IT
INVESTIGATES ITSELF WOULD BE
UNIQUE HERE.
AND WE ALSO SUGGEST THAT TERM
IS WRONG HAD.
BUT EARLIER THAT HE HAD BEEN
PURSUING OPPOSE CERTIFICATION
FOR THIS AGENCY FOR SOMETIME.
THAT WOULD HAVE BEEN.
IT CAPS AWAITING THE AGENCY SO
THAT WOULD HAVE HAD ALSO HAD AYE
BUILT INTO IT AS WELL SO THERE
IS AN INHERENT CONFLICT WHY
WOULD YOU ALSO MEANS BC COMPOSER
VACATION AT SAME TIME.
SO.
IT'S A LITTLE CONSISTENT TO SAY
THERE IS A CONFLICT BUILT IN SO
WE'RE HAPPY KEEP WORKING WITH
THEM.
TO SEE IF THERE'S A WAY TO
TRAIN BETTER OR TO PURSUE POST
CERTIFICATION WITH THEM BUT AT
THIS POINT WHERE OPPOSE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SIR.
SEEING NO FURTHER TEAMED UP
WITH.
HOW
JUST FOR CLARIFICATION CHAIN HOW
HOW IS IT THAT YOU CAN AND I
DON'T UNDERSTAND THAT HOW YOU
WOULD LOSE NINE POSITIONS IF?
IF WE FOUNDED THIS.
SO THE SPECIAL BUT THE
CLASSIFICATION THAT THEY WOULD
BE CHANGING THIS TO THE ONLY
FOLKS THAT WOULD ULTIMATELY BE
ELIGIBLE TO TO FILL THOSE
POSITIONS. ARE FROM CDC ARE
ULTIMATELY THEY MAINTAIN THAT
CLASSIFICATION CURRENTLY OUR
FOLKS WOULD NOT BE ELIGIBLE OF
FOR THOSE POSITIONS.
DOES THE DEPARTMENT HAVE A
RESPONSE TO THAT.
WELL IT DOES HE IN REGARDS THE
LAST STATEMENT CDC. IF YOU MEET
THE QUALIFICATIONS YOU CAN COME
FROM A POLICE DEPARTMENT AS LONG
AS YOU MEET QUALIFICATIONS FOR
SPECIAL AGENT YOU CAN. IT'S NOT
SOLELY FROM DEPARTMENT
CORRECTIONS.
A.
RJR TO KERN INVESTIGATORS YET
WILL ALTHOUGH THEY'RE NOT
SPECIAL AGENTS ARE TO KERN
INVESTIGATORS ARE FROM FROM
POLICE DEPARTMENTS.
IN REGARDS TO NOTIFICATION AS WE
WENT TO THE BCP PROCESS.
BUT WE DID SEE EACH OTHER. POSE
CERTIFICATION FOR ABOUT A TWO
YEAR PERIOD MEETING WITH POST
OFTEN ON AND AND WHEN WE RECEIVE
THE NOTIFICATION FROM POST WE
KNEW WE HAD A PROBLEM WE
RECEIVED A LETTER FROM POST.
AT THAT POINT IN TIME.
.
SI A SILLY A BECAME AWARE OF THE
VCP WE MET WITH CS LA A I'VE
COMMUNICATED WITH THEM SEVERAL
TIMES BACK AND FORTH TRYING TO
US AT A MEETING WE HAVE BEEN
OFFICE AT THAT MEETING.
TO TRY TO RESOLVE THE ISSUE.
I STILL THINK WHEN YOU READ THE
POST REGULATION IT'S PRETTY
CLEAR WHAT POSTS IS ASKING.
I'M SO I I STILL THINK IT'S
GONNA BE IT WOULD BE AN UP HILL
BATTLE. FROM OUR PERSPECTIVE WE
CERTAINLY DON'T WANT WITHIN SEE
ASSEMBLY A WERE REALLY CABBAGES
FOCUS ON OUR MISSION. IN WHAT
WE'RE DOING AND HOW BEST FULFILL
OUR MISSION.
IF CO CILIATES WILLING TO MEET
WITH US WITH POSTS WERE CERTAIN
WILLING TO DO IT BUT I JUST
DON'T SEE POSTS CHANGING THAT
REGULATION WHEN YOU READ THE
POST REGULATION ONE THOUSAND
ONE.
IT'S VERY CLEAR. IN TERMS OF.
WHAT THE CRITERIA IS TO BE A
POST TO BE A POST AGENCY ITSELF?
THAT'S OUR RESPONSE TO IT BUT
CERTAINLY WILLING TO WORK WITH
CS ALLEVIATE BUT.
I I SEE IS AN UPHILL BATTLE IN
THE MEANTIME WE'RE WE'RE
SURVIVING A RETIRED ANNUITANTS.
WE HAVE A CASELOAD AND THE
PROBLEM CONTINUES I'D LIKE TO
ASK OIL WELL YES IF YOU CAN. TO
PLEASE ASSIST US IN LEARNING
MORE ABOUT THE VIEWPOINT OF THIS
REQUEST AND TO ORGANIZE A
MEETING WITH THE RELEVANT
STAKEHOLDERS THE ALEJO AND
LEGISLATIVE STAFF TO DISCUSS THE
ISSUES AND CONCERNS THAT ARE
BROUGHT FORWARD WITH THIS BCP.
I'D LIKE TO ASK IF POSSIBLE FOR
THIS MEETING TO BE CONVENED AS
SOON AS PRACTICAL GOAL. FOR US
TO INFORMER MAY REVISION ACTION
ON THIS ISSUE RIGHT ABSOLUTELY
AND WITH THAT WE WILL HOLD ISSUE
SIX OPEN AND THANK ON.
WE ARE.
WE HAVE OUR FRESHEST MEMBER OF
THE ASSEMBLY WHO'S HERE AND
SEEING HER I'D LIKE TO INVITE
OUR.
THANK YOU
.
I THINK HERE VOTER SUPPRESSION
SO CLEAN WELCOME.
WELL THANK YOU SO VERY MUCH
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
I'M HERE TO SPEAK ON THAT CHAFEE
BUDGET PROPOSAL.
SO CURRENTLY THE CALIFORNIA
CHAFEE GRANT PROGRAM ASSIST SAP
PROVIDES ASSISTANCE TO FOSTER
YOUTH FOR EDUCATIONAL OR CAREER
TRAINING.
YOUTH BETWEEN THE AGES OF
SIXTEEN AND TWENTY TWO ARE
ELIGIBLE FOR FIVE THOUSAND
DOLLARS PER YEAR.
HOWEVER THIS AGE CUT OFF CAN BE
UNREALISTIC FOR MANY FOSTER
YOUTH.
IN FACT I OFTENTIMES FORMER%
FOSTER YOUTH DO NOT EVEN HEAR
ABOUT THE CHAFEE GRANT PROGRAM
UNTIL AFTER THEY HAVE AGED OUT
OF ELIGIBILITY.
THIS PROPOSAL WILL DO TWO
THINGS.
IT EXTENDS THE AGE LIMIT TO
TWENTY SIX AND IT PROVIDES AN
ADDITIONAL FOUR MILLION DOLLARS
IN STATE FUNDING TO SUPPORT
ADDITIONAL YOUTH IN THE PROGRAM.
AS A FORMER COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICT TRUSTEE I CAN SPEAK TO
THE IMPORTANCE OF THIS BUDGET
REQUEST AND THE OPPORTUNITY IT
WILL PROVIDE.
OVER FIFTY TWO PERCENT OF THE
STUDENTS WHO ATTEND THE LOS
ANGELES COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICT LIVE BELOW THE POVERTY
LINE.
LESS THAN FIVE PERCENT OF THE
FORMER FOSTER TEUTONS FOUGHT
FORMER FOSTER TO STUDENTS WHO
ATTEND.
GRADUATES AND THOSE THAT DO
SPEND AN AVERAGE OF SIX YEARS IN
COLLEGE TRYING TO DO SO.
AND A FOSTER YOUTH TOWN HALL I
CONVENE SOME YEARS AGO MANY
YOUTH TALKED ABOUT THE THREE
LEGGED STOOL THAT INCLUDES
EDUCATION HOUSING AND
EMPLOYMENT.
THE MOST IMPORTANT LEG FOR THEM
WAS EMPLOYMENT
BECAUSE AT STABILIZED EVERY
OTHER ASPECT OF THEIR LIFE LIKE
BEING ABLE TO TRAVEL.
TO SCHOOL TO EAT TO PAY RENT TO
BUY BOOKS ACCEPT IRA.
BEING ABLE TO ACCESS THE DEATHS
ADDITIONAL CHAFEE FUNDING WILL
CONTINUE TO STRENGTHEN THIS TOOL
ENCOURAGE FOSTER STUDENTS TO
STAY ENGAGED IN THEIR EDUCATION.
AND LET THEM KNOW THAT WE ARE
WILLING AND ABLE TO INVEST IN
THEIR SUCCESS.
HERE TO TESTIFY WITH ME ARE
CRYSTAL HARRIS A FORMER FOSTER
YOUTH AND GRADUATE OF THE
UNIVERSITY OF SAN FRANCISCO
SCHOOL OF LAW. AND JESSE AGUILAR
THE DIRECTOR OF BEYOND FOSTER
CARE AT JOURNEY HOUSE AND ALSO
LEAD ORGANIZER ON THIS ISSUE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION
OF THIS PROPOSAL.
GOOD AFTERNOON A WITH A WAS
MENTIONED MY NAME IS JUSTIN I'M
HERE ON BEHALF OF JENNY HOUSE.
OF FOR THE PAST THIRTY FIVE
YEARS.
JENNY HOUSE HAS ASSISTED FOSS
YOU CAN IN ROLLING AND COMPETE
IN THEIR HIGHER EDUCATION
JENNY'S.
WE'VE FIVE SEEN FIRST HAND ARE
I'D HAD FIRSTHAND EXPERIENCE IN
DEALING WITH STUDENTS IN THE
FOSTER CARE. IDG TEAM AND THEN
RETURN AGE TWENTY TO TWENTY
FIVE.
AND IN SOME CASES FOLKS WERE
RETURNING A CLOSER TO THEIR
THIRTIES AND ARE JUST FEELING
READY TO EITHER START OR RETURN
TO SCHOOL.
PART OF OUR INTAKE PROCESS ISN'T
IT ARE AND AN ASSESSMENT PROCESS
IS TO DETERMINE. IF ANY OF THE
ERA OF THE YOUNG PEOPLE COMING
INTO OUR PROGRAM AND RECEIVED A
HELP FOR MANY PROGRAMMERS ARE
AGENCY.
TOO OFTEN THAT WE CONCLUDE THAT
OUR FOLKS DID NOT ACCESS ANY OF
THE SERVICES.
OR THAT THEY WOULD HAVE
QUALIFIED FOR SUCH AS THE
INDEPENDENT LIVING PROGRAM
EXTENDED FAR SECURE TV GRANT.
ARE AND THERE'S A LIST OF
REASONS WHY FOSTER YOUTH DO NOT
TAXES THESE CRUCIAL SUPPORT.
BUT WE KNOW THAT THIRTY PERCENT
OF HOUSE YOU'D BECOME HOMELESS
WITH IN THE FIRST SIX MONTHS OF
LIVING CARE.
WE KNOW THAT THIRTY PERCENT OF
YOUNG PEOPLE WHO HAD TO FOSTER
CARE.
YOUNG WOMEN WHO EXIT FOSTER
CARE BECOME PREGNANT WITHIN THE
FIRST SIX MONTHS.
A LIVING CARE.
AND IT IS ALSO TRUE THAT YOU GO
INTO SURVIVAL MODE WHEN THEY
LEAVE OUR CARE BECAUSE THEY ARE
LEFT TO FEND FOR THEMSELVES.
THIS MEANS THAT INCOME IS A
HIGHER PRIORITY THAN WORKING
TOWARDS A LONG TERM GOAL.
IT MEANS THAT PUTTING FOOD ON
THE TABLE FOR THEIR CHILD.
IS A BIGGER PRIORITY THEM
PASSING THE TEST.
AND THIS OFTEN LEADS
TO HAVING TO DROP OUT OF SCHOOL
TO WORK AND PROVIDE.
OTHERS NEVER HAD THE CHANCE TO
START FROM THE VERY BEGINNING.
MANY EXPRESS THEIR VERY SIMPLY
THEY ARE TIRED OF BEING GOVERNED
BY AN INSTITUTION.
SO WHEN THEY TURN EIGHTEEN
EMANCIPATE THE CLOSE THE DOOR
BEHIND THEMSELVES FORBIDDING
THEM VALUABLE SUPPORT PROGRAMS
AND RESOURCES THAT THEY WOULD
QUALIFY FOR.
WITH EVERYTHING THAT WE KNOW.
ABOUT THE DEVELOPMENT OF THE
BRAIN SCIENCE RESEARCH WE KNOW
THAT YOUNG PEOPLE DON'T DEVELOP
CRITICAL THINKING AND DECISION
MAKING ABILITY.
AND TALK UNTIL IT LEAVES THE
TWENTY FIFTH BIRTHDAY.
THIS IS CRUCIAL IS HIGHER
EDUCATION REQUIRES DISCIPLINE
THAT MANY FOSTER YOU.
FORTUNATELY.
AND NEVER DEVELOP LOVING CARE.
THEY HAVE TO LEARN ABOUT LIFE
THE HARD WAY.
ARE THESE INVESTMENTS IN TV
PROGRAM IS ABOUT GIVING ALL THE
FUSS YOU THE CHANCE.
TO LIVE SELF SUSTAINING LIVES.
IT'S ABOUT GIVING THOSE WHO HAD
NEVER HAD A CHANCE TO SUCCEED IN
THEIR EDUCATIONAL JOURNEY AND
OPPORTUNITY AN OPPORTUNITY TO DO
SO.
WE KNOW THAT THESE INVESTMENTS
GOING A LONG WAY IN IMPROVING
THE EDUCATIONAL OUTCOMES.
AS THESE PROGRAMS ABOUT ARE
UNIQUE IN THAT THEY ALLOW
STUDENTS TO PAY FOR SCHOOL
RELATED EXPENSES. BEYOND TUITION
AND FEES.
BOOKS FOOD CHILDCARE RENT.
SCHOOL SUPPLIES
IT'S FOR THESE REASONS THAT WERE
URGING SUPPORT ON THIS CRUCIAL
INVESTMENT.
MISTER AGUILAR.
HELLO MY NAME IS CRYSTAL.
AND I WOULD LIKE TO SAY THAT I
WENT TO.
COMMUNITY COLLEGE BECAUSE A
TEACHER UNDERSTOOD BEANO TOLD ME
TO START COLLEGE.
HE ASKED ME WHAT WOULD I BE
DOING AT THE AGE OF TWENTY FIVE
AND AT EIGHTEEN I HAD NO PLAN.
SO THEREFORE I DECIDED TO GO TO
COMMUNITY COLLEGE.
THAT TIME I WAS VERY CRITICAL IN
MY ACCESS TO FINANCIAL AID.
SHOULD I HAVE WAITED TWO OR
THREE YEARS LATER I WOULD NOT
HAVE BEEN ELIGIBLE FOR THE FULL
AMOUNT OF THE CHAFEE GRANT.
FOR ME.
STARTING EDUCATION AT THE AGE OF
EIGHTEEN.
CHAFEE MET MONEY FOR HOUSING FOR
CLOTHING TRANSPORTATION.
SECURITY AND MORE THAN ANYTHING
FOR PEACE OF MIND.
NOW ONE COULD SAY WHY NOT JUST
GET WORK STUDY WELL WORK STUDY
IS CAPPED AT TWENTY HOURS ENDED
DOESN'T OFTEN COVER THE RISING
COSTS OF RENT AND FOOD.
AFTER THREE YEARS AT COMMUNITY
COLLEGE ADVENTUROUS FOR TO UCLA.
AND WHEN I WAS AT UCLA THE
FINANCIAL BURDEN BECAME SO HARD
THAT ALL I COULD REALLY DO WAS
WORK AT SCHOOL AND GO TO
CLASSES.
I COULD NOT FULLY EXPERIENCE IN
BE I COULD NOT BE A VIABLE PART
OF THE COLLEGE EXPERIENCE
WHICH MEANT I COULD NOT AFFORD
TO JOIN A SORORITY. I COULD NOT
AFFORD TO DO FREE WORK IN AN
INTERNSHIP
I COULD NOT AFFORD TO STUDY
ABROAD.
ALL I COULD DO WAS WORK AND GO
TO CLASS.
THIS WAS EXPRESSED
IN AN INTERESTING WAY THAT HAD
TO DO WITH THE CHAFEE GRANT.
IN MY TWENTY THIRD YEAR OF LIFE
IS WHEN I WAS GIVEN THE AMAZING
OPPORTUNITY. TO WORK WITH THE
NOW ATTORNEY GENERAL IN DC.
BUT I WAS TWENTY THREE.
AND THAT PROGRAM WOULD NOT ALLOW
ME TO WORK WORK STUDY.
SO IN BC I HAD NO EXTRA
FINANCIAL AID I WAS UNABLE TO
WORK WORK STUDY SO I HAD NO
MONEY TO PAY. FOR HOUSING OR
FOOD.
AND I DIDN'T HAVE THE CHAFEE
GRANT WHICH I WAS USED TO
GETTING FROM THE AGES FROM
EIGHTEEN TO TWENTY TWO. BUT IT
WAS CAPPED.
AND IN THAT VERY SEMESTER I
ACCRUE THREE THOUSAND DOLLARS
WORTH OF DEBT. THAT TOOK ME
THREE THREE YEARS TO PAY OFF I
ACTUALLY DIDN'T PAY IT OFF
UNTIL.
MY SECOND YEAR OF LAW SCHOOL.
AND BECAUSE OF THAT DEBT.
BECAUSE OF MY LACK OF ACCESS TO
THE CHAFEE GRANT BECAUSE OF MY
AGE.
IT TOOK AWAY SOME OPPORTUNITIES
FOR ME TO BE ABLE TO FULLY
ENJOY.
MY EDUCATIONAL OPPORTUNITY IN MY
EDUCATIONAL EXPERIENCE.
FOR ME THE CHAFEE MEANS THE
ABILITY.
TO BE ABLE TO HAVE MONEY WITHOUT
MAKING EDUCATIONAL SACRIFICES.
AND FOR THESE REASONS.
I BELIEVE THAT YOU ALL SHOULD
PASS THIS BILL.
THANK YOU MISS HARRIS.
NEXT WE'LL HEAR FROM VALERIE
EARLY ENOUGH WE CAN MAKE A SPOT
FOR HER. TO BE APPRECIATED.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
COMMITTING I'M VALERIE EARLY
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES AT
THIS POINT.
WE HAVE NO FORMAL POSITION ON
THE BILL CLEARLY IT'S AN
IMPORTANT ASPECT IN WE WERE MORE
THAN WILLING TO WORK WITH YOU
ALL IF THIS IS A. PRIORITY FOR
THE COMMITTEE THANK YOU MA'AM.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
THE A MORE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
OUT WE'RE ONLY JUST LEARNING
ABOUT THIS PROPOSAL BUT WE'RE
HAPPY TO MEET WITH ADVOCATES AND
PROVIDE TECHNICAL SYSTEMS AS
NECESSARY.
BELOW IN THE COMMENTS.
I WHAT WE WILL NOW TAKE PUBLIC
COMMENT ON ISSUE FOR.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS MY NAME IS QUINTON
FOSTER.
I'VE WORKED IN THIS ENVIRONMENT
FOR QUITE SOME TIME TODAY I'M
NOT HERE AS THE DIRECTOR OF
CALIFORNIA CLIMATE FOR THE
ENVIRONMENTAL DEFENSE FUND. I AM
HERE AS A FORMER FOSTER YOUTH
THIS A ISSUE THAT YOU ARE
CONSIDERING TAKING UP IS
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT AND WHAT
I'VE DRAFTED A VERY NICE WAY OF
NOTES THAT BE MORE THAN HAPPYTO
READ TO YOU TODAY. FOR THE SAKE
OF TIME AND GRAVITY OF THIS
PARTICULAR ISSUE YOU'VE HEARD
FROM MY CAR MY FORMER COLLEAGUES
ABOUT HIRING CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT THIS IS. AS A FORMER
FOSTER YOUTH I CAN ATTEST TO
THAT WHEN I WAS EMANCIPATED
THERE WERE NO BRIDGE PROGRAMS
FOR ME AT THAT TIME. I HAD TO
MAKE THE DECISION BETWEEN
WHETHER TO SURVIVE FOR ME I
STAND BEFORE YOU AS
THE FIRST OF MY FAMILY TO
GRADUATE FROM UNIVERSITY. WITH A
DEGREE IN ECONOMICS IN TWO
MASTERS DEGREES AND PUBLIC
POLICY AND PUBLIC ADMINISTRATION
WHAT I CAN TELL YOU IS THAT IF
THERE WERE PROGRAMS LIKE THIS
AVAILABLE FOR ME AT THAT TIME. I
MAY HAVE.
ACHIEVE THAT LEVEL OF SUCCESS
MUCH SOONER THIS IS INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT PROVIDING THAT NEXT
WRONG AND THAT LADDER OF UPWARD
MOBILITY FOR OUR MOST VULNERABLE
POPULATION. IS A MORAL
OBLIGATION OF THIS LEGISLATURE
AND YOU HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
DO THAT BEFORE YOU TODAY. IAM
PROUD TO STAND HERE AND THAT MY
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT OF THIS
VERY IMPORTANT ITEM.
MY NAME IS DOCTOR NEXT TO TARA A
I'M NOT AFFILIATED I'M HERE ON
MY OWN.
FIRST I JUST WANT TO SAY THAT
ALUM REALLY PROUD TO BE
AFFILIATED WITH CRYSTAL BY BEING
UCLA GUARDIAN SCHOLAR.
WE'RE BOTH THERE TOGETHER AS
FORMER FOSTER YOUTH GETTING OUR
DEGREES.
AND.
BRIDGE PROGRAMS LIKE THAT ARE A
BIG DEAL I HAVE THREE VERY QUICK
POINTS IF YOU'LL INDULGE ME.
THERE ARE A WIDE RANGE OF SOCIAL
SERVICES HEALTH SERVICES AND
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES.
THAT.
AS TRANSITION AGE YOUTH FORMER
FOSTER YOUTH GET UP UNTIL AGE
TWENTY SIX.
AND I KNOW THERE'S
REPRESENTATIVES HERE FROM CWD A
AND I SEE VALERIE IN THEY CAN
ATTEST TO WHY. THE SERVICES ARE
PROVIDED A FORMER FOSTER YOUTH
THEY EVEN GO TOWARDS ADMISSIONS.
WHY THEN DOES THE CHIEF GRANT
STOP AT TWENTY TWO?
SO THAT'S MY FIRST POINT
SECOND POINT IS THE ADDITIONAL
FOUR MILLION DOLLARS WE WOULD I
WOULD APPRECIATE BEING SOMEHOW
SET ASIDE BY RULE FOR THOSE
OLDER YOUTH WERE OVER THE AGE OF
TWENTY TWO.
AND THEN THE THIRD POINT IS THAT
IN THE CONSTELLATION OF ALL THE
MANY DIFFERENT FINANCIALLY
PROGRAMS.
ALMOST ALL OF THEM I THINK
ACTUALLY ALL OF THEM HINGED ON
SATISFACTORY ACADEMIC PROGRESS
WHEN WE SPEAK TO A THREE LEGGED
STOOL THAT OUR NEWEST ASSEMBLY
WOMAN.
MENTIONED.
IF THEY LOSE THE CHAFEE GRANT
THEY LOSE EVERYTHING.
SO IT WOULD ACTUALLY MAKE ME
VERY HAPPY FOR MY YOUNGER
BROTHERS AND SISTERS IF.
THE CHIEF GRANT WERE OT
CONTINGENT UPON SATISFACTORY
ACADEMIC PROGRESS.
THANK YOU THANK YOU SIR.
HELEN ROTH DOWDEN SPI NET WHICH
IS A FOSTER FAMILY AGENCY AND
WHERE FULL SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME'S AS MONEY IS ON
THE SECOND A CORNER FOR THE ANTI
RECIDIVISM COALITION ALSO KNOWN
AS A RC. A WE'RE HERE IN
SUPPORT.
OF THE ANTI RECIDIVISM COALITION
IS A. ORGANIZATION.
COMPRISED OF FORMING CARCERI
INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE DEVOTED
THEIR LIVES TO. BEING PRODUCTIVE
MEMBERS IT AND THE COMMUNITY I'M
AS A SECULAR COORDINATOR I GOING
ONCE A MONTH THE DJJ FACILITIES.
AND HAVE HAD THE PLEASURE TO
MENTOR YOUTH A MOST OF WHICH
HAVE BEEN IN THE FOSTER CARE
SYSTEM.
SO I'VE SEEN FIRSTHAND YOU KNOW
HOW THEY'RE THEIR JOURNEY IN
LIFE HAS HAS THE ODDS OF ALWAYS
BEEN STACKED AGAINST THEM.
YET THERE'S STILL ASPIRE TO
PURSUE HIGHER EDUCATION.
UNFORTUNATE MOST OF THEM WILL
COME HOME UNTIL THEY'RE IN THEIR
MID TWENTIES.
SO YOU KNOW THAT WOULD HAVE TO
STRUGGLE TO MAKE ENDS MEET AND
TO BE ABLE TO. GET INTO. A
HIGHER LEARNING.
OPPORTUNITIES IT'S OF SO I
STRONGLY URGE SUPPORT THANK
THANK YOU SIR.
I'M SECURE MICRO WITH WESTERN
CENTER ALONG PARTY ABOUT WE TO
SUPPORT THOSE AUGMENTATION THE
FUNDING ON FOR CHAFEE GRANTS AND
URGE YOUR ADOPTION THANK YOU
THANK YOU SIR.
HI LUCY SAUCEDO CARTER WITH THE
YOUTH LAW CENTER AND WE ARE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS PROPOSAL.
WE CAN.
SINGLE FURTHER PUBLIC COMMENT ON
ISSUE FOR A BRING IT UP TO THE
DIETS FOR ANY COMMENTS YOU MAY
HAVE.
I'D LIKE TO THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD IT.
SPEAKS HIGHLY OF YOUR.
JOINING OUR MEMBERSHIP TO HAVE
SUCH A THOUGHTFUL AND
APPROPRIATE. I'M ASKING FRONT OF
THIS COMMITTEE AND REALLY DO
APPRECIATE YOU COMING FORWARD
AND TESTIFYING HERE TODAY.
WITH THAT WE WILL HOLD THIS
ISSUE OPEN AND RETURN BACK TO
ISSUE SEVEN IN OUR AGENDA THANK
YOU THANK YOU THANK YOU MEMBERS
.
I TURN. UP MY PRISTINE DOES THE
CAN FROM OUR SIDE OF THE
DIRECTOR AND THIS IS JOHN GAVE
HER PROJECT DIRECTOR FOR THE
WICK THE WHIP PROJECT.
I THIS IS A VERY COMPLETE
COMPREHENSIVE DESCRIPTION IN
THE.
.
AGENDA I THINK YOU'RE TO
QUESTIONS ONE WAS ABOUT WHETHER
THE SPR HAD BEEN APPROVED IN
THAT IS THE CASE IT HAS BEEN AND
IT DOES ALIGN WITH THE SPRING
FINANCE LETTER.
BOB WOULD YOU LIKE COME FURTHER
OVERVIEW OF THE PROJECT.
I THINK THAT'S OKAY ACTUALLY.
ARE.
OFTEN THAT OVER TO JOHN.
OKAY TH A BRIEF OVERVIEW OF
PROJECT.
.
THIS IS A YUBA PROJECT IS A
HUNDRED PERCENT FEDERALLY FUNDED
PROJECTS TO COMPLY WITH THE A
FEDERAL MANDATE. THE.
THE HEALTHY HUNGER FREE KIDS
ACT OF TWO THOUSAND TEN.
TO.
AUTOMATE THE PEN THE ISSUANCE
AND REDEMPTION OF WHAT BENEFITS
THE CURRENTLY A MANUAL SYSTEM.
SO TO AUTOMATE THE BRICK
BENEFITS V. E. D. T. BY TWENTY
TWENTY OCTOBER ONE TWENTY
TWENTY.
SO THIS PROJECT IS I ACTUALLY
TWO PARTS TO THIS PROJECT. IT
ONE TO TRANSFER IT A NEW WICK MI
ES FROM OPERATING FROM ANOTHER
STATE TRANSFER SYSTEM.
AND THEN CONFIGURED FOR
CALIFORNIA'S REQUIREMENTS AND
THEN INTERFACE IT WITH THE
EXISTING EBT SYSTEM.
FOR AGAIN THE ISSUE INTO
REDEMPTION OF THOSE BENEFITS SO
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE DOING HERE AND
THE PROPOSAL HERE. IS REALLY
FAST FOR SPENDING AUTHORITY FOR
THE SYSTEM INTEGRATOR.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND I
WILL.
THERE ARE LESS WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE WE
HAVE REVIEWED BOTH THE SPRING
FINANCE LETTER AND THE NOW
APPROVE SPECIAL PROJECT REPORT
AND HAVE NO CONCERNS TO REYES
THANK YOU.
ANY PUBLIC COMMENT ON ISSUE
SEVEN.
SEEING NONE ALL BRING IT UP TO
THE DYESS AND SEEING NO COMMENTS
WE WILL HOLD ISSUE SEVEN OPEN
AND MOVE ON TO ISSUE ONE. WITHIN
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
AGING
.
WHEN YOU'RE READY DIRECTOR.
IT'S GOING TO TAKE A MORNING BUT
THRILLED TO GET AFTER HIM DEPUTY
LARA COMING FROM THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF AGING AND WITH ME.
INTRUSION BY CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF AGING GOOD
AFTERNOON.
AFTERNOON
AND THE AGENDA FOR TODAY I KNOW
PERSON PROVIDES A REALLY I'M
PRETTY DETAILED AND DESCRIPTION
OF OUR SPRING FINANCE FIGHTERS
HOLD ME JUST. ON BRIEFLY
SUMMARIZE AND SEE IF YOU HAVE
ANY QUESTIONS.
THE DEPARTMENT OF AGING HAS HAD
AN INTERAGENCY AGREEMENT WITH
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES
SINCE TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN TO
DELIVER ARM SNAPPED ED.
A. PROGRAMS AND SERVICES.
AND EDUCATION.
THROUGH OUR AREA AGENCIES ON
AGING AND THIS PROPOSAL SEEKS T
EXPAND BOTH OUR STATE OPERATIONS
FUNDING AS WELL AS THE LOCAL
ASSISTANCE FUNDING.
SNAP IT INTERVENTIONS MUST BE
EVIDENCE BASED NUTRITION
EDUCATION AND OBESITY PREVENTION
PROGRAMS.
AND SO USING THE AREA AGENCIES
ON AGING HAS BEEN A GOOD NEXUS
ON BOTH FOR SOCIAL SERVICES AND
AS AND THAT THE AREA AGENCIES
ALREADY ARE PROVIDING NUTRITION
SERVICES. ARM AND ESPECIALLY
THROUGH THE OLDER AMERICANS ACT
TARGETED TO LOW INCOME
INDIVIDUALS AND COMMUNITIES
WHICH IS THE NEXUS WITH WITH
SNAP ED.
AND WE ALSO PROVIDE.
EVIDENCE BASED
HEALTH PROMOTION PROGRAMS
THROUGH OUR TITLE THREE D.
PROGRAMS WELL SO THE NEXUS IS
DEFINITELY THERE.
HOWEVER ON BASED ON OUR
EXPERIENCE TO DATE IN TERMS OF
BEING INVOLVED WITH SNAP ED.
OVER THE PAST SEVERAL YEARS WE
CERTAINLY REALIZE THAT THE AREA
AGENCIES ON AGING NEED MORE
GUIDANCE AND TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE ARM AND MONITORING
FOR THE PLANNING AND DELIVERY OF
THE SERVICES THIRTY NOT
UNCOMPLICATED. ARM PROGRAMS TO
DELIVER AND DECIDING WHICH
EVIDENCE BASED PROGRAMS TO
PROVIDE AND ATTRACT AN AUDIENCE
ARM.
EXCEPT TESTING AND AND LEARNING.
AS THEY GO.
EQUALLY AS IMPORTANT THE
PARTICIPATING.
.
SO THAT IS AN ISSUE IN TERMS OF
AS AN TERM AND OUR OUR STAFFING
LEVELS. ON EQUALLY IMPORTANT WE
REALIZE THAT THE AREA AGENCIES
THAT ARE PARTICIPATING AT THIS
POINT.
THAT WORK INVOLVED IN
DELIVERING THESE PROGRAMS.
IS NOT SUFFICIENT WITH THE
FUNDING THAT THEY'RE CURRENTLY
RECEIVING AT LEAST A NUMBER OF
THEM IN TERMS OF THE BASELINE
FUNDING THAT GET TO OPERATE. AND
MEET ALL OF THESE REQUIREMENTS
SO THIS SNAP IT.
PROPOSAL OF BEFORE YOU WOULD
INCREASE CTA'S.
OPERATING STATE BUDGET FOR THIS
PROGRAM TO A TOTAL OF SIX
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR
FISCAL YEAR SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN
AND ONGOING. WHICH WOULD ALLOW
US TO INCREASE OUR ON HEALTH
PROGRAM SPECIALIST POSITION TO A
FULL TIME.
LEVEL RIGHT NOW IT'S I THINK
THREE THREE POINT POINT THREE
FIVE.
AND THEN MAKE THE TO LIMITED
TERM POSITIONS A A ALICE
POSITIONS THAT WE HAVE FOR THIS
PROGRAM PERMANENT SO THAT.
YOU KNOW THAT EXPERTISE STAYS
WITH US LONG TERM I'M MOVING
FORWARD.
AND THEN ALSO PROVIDE ADDITIONAL
I'M A STATE OPERATIONS RESOURCES
IN TERMS OF OUR INCORRECT ON
COSTS AND SOME SPECIAL STUDIES
THAT WE FILLER ARE IMPORTANT TO
DO.
WITH THESE.
UP WITH THIS KIND OF
INFRASTRUCTURE INCREASE AT THE
STATE LEVEL ON IN PLACE. BOTH
SOCIAL SERVICES NCTA BELIEVES
THAT WILL THEN HAVE SUFFICIENT
RESOURCES TO REALLY BE ABLE TO
AND PROVIDE SUFFICIENT TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE TO THE.
SIXTEEN PARTICIPATING AREA
AGENCIES ON AGING TO HELP THEM.
KIND OF INCREASE THEIR TARGETING
THE SELECTION OF PROGRAMS THAT
WOULD BE PROBABLY MOST LIKELY
BENEFICIAL IN THEIR COMMUNITY.
AND HELP THEM TO INCREASE THEIR
PERFORMANCE IN TERMS OF MEETING
THAT THE PROGRAM UP PERFORMANCE
GOALS.
SO THIS.
BUT EQUALLY AS IMPORTANT.
ARE FROM THE LOCAL ASSIST
INSIDE THE PROPOSAL INCLUSIVE
INCLUDES ANOTHER ONE POINT THREE
MILLION AND LOCAL ASSISTANCE.
EXPENDITURE AUTHORITY FOR ITEMS
EIGHTEEN AFFECTS QUICKER
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN AND ONGOING SO
THAT THOSE SIXTEEN PARTICIPATING
AREA AGENCIES ALL RECEIVE AT
LEAST A BASELINE OF FORTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS. TO OPERATE
THIS PROGRAM RIGHT NOW.
ABOUT HALF OF THE AREA AGENCIES
ARE RECEIVING LESS THAN THAT AND
THEY REALLY DO NEED TO HAVE. A
CERTAIN LEVEL OF BASE FUNDING TO
BE ABLE TO TO OPERATE THESE
PROGRAMS. AND EFFECTIVELY
THERE'S NO STATE MATCH.
FOR THIS GRANT AND THE FUNDING
IS A HUNDRED PERCENT FROM THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
SO MAY I JUST ASK IF THERE ARE
ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
HELLO.
PUBLISHED WAS RIGHT APARTMENT
FINANCE WE SUPPORT THE REQUEST
THE REASON STATED BY THE
PARLIAMENT AND I WANT TO CLARIFY
THAT THE AUGMENTATION WILL
RESULT IN A BASE FUNDING EIGHTY
THOUSAND PER PARTICIPATING
TRIPLE ACT. OKAY.
EARLIER CHECK TO BRAZIL
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE.
WE'VE CONDUCTED INITIAL REVIEW
THE SPRING FINANCE LETTER REYES
NO CONCERNS AT THIS TIME BECAME.
ANY PUBLIC COMMENT ON ISSUE ONE
FOR DEPARTMENT OF AGING.
SEEING NONE.
THIS
ISSUE WAS WELL RECEIVED AND WE
WILL HOLD THIS OPEN.
THANK YOU WE WILL NOW MOVE ON TO
ISSUE ONE FOR THE CALIFORNIA
SENIOR LEGISLATURE.
SO LOSE PUSH ROD APARTMENT
FINANCE WILL BE PRESENTING THIS
REQUEST.
THE COMPANIES WHO HAVE IT
LEGISLATURE REQUIRES THE
REAPPROPRIATION OF THE
UNENCUMBERED BALANCE OF THE
TWENTY SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN
GENERAL FUND APPROPRIATION.
SO FOR SOME CONTEXT THIS YEAR
LEGISLATURE RECEIVE A GENERAL
FUND APPROPRIATION OF. TWO
HUNDRED SEVENTY FIVE THOUSAND
AND TWENTY SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN.
AS TEMPORARY FUNDING WHILE THE
ORGANIZATION I FIGURED OUT LONG
TERM FINANCING PLAN. THEY ALSO
HAVE A TWENTY SIXTY FIVE
THOUSAND OF UNSPENT FUNDS FROM
THERE TWENTY SIXTEEN SEVENTEEN
APPROPRIATIONS. FOR A TOTAL OF
SIX HUNDRED FORTY THOUSAND
SPEND IN CURRENT YEAR.
PLUS YOURSELVES PROJECTING
EXPENDITURES OF ROUGHLY THREE
HUNDRED FORTY THOUSAND.
WHICH WOULD LEAVE A BALANCE OF
ABOUT THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND
THIS IS
WHAT WE ESTIMATE RIGHT NOW WE
NEED TO BE A RE APPROPRIATED
THROUGH THIS REQUEST SOME HAPPY
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
DOCTOR CONNELLY I HAVE YOU NEXT
ON OURS BUT TOM I MAY PASSED THE
QUESTIONS AFTERWARDS IF THAT'S
OKAY WITH YOU OKAY. I'M WE HAVE
NO ADDITIONAL COMMENTS LIKE I
THINK THE THE INITIAL COMMENT
THAT I MADE IT THERE ARE PRIVATE
BY PRIOR BUDGET HEARING. IN
TERMS OF THAT.
DEFERRED THE DIFFERENTIATING
WHAT THE VALUE IS.
IN TERMS OF CSL COMING TO
DEPARTMENT OF AGING VERSUS
SAYING IT DEPARTMENT OF GENERAL
SERVICES WE WOULD STILL NEED TO.
CHARGE FOR THE ADMINISTRATIVE
SUPPORT.
THAT WE WILL BE OFFERING AT THE
DEPARTMENT.
.
AND THEN THERE'S THE SO.
HOW WAS THERE A SAVINGS THERE IN
TERMS OF YOU KNOW OPERATIONAL?
FROM AN OPERATIONAL PERSPECTIVE
AND I THINK YOU KNOW STILL ON
THINKING ABOUT THIS AND
REFLECTING WITH OTHERS ABOUT
THIS AS WELL. THAT.
KIND OF THAT. THE MORPHING ADS
TO HOUSE CSL REMAINS INDEPENDENT
WITHIN A DEPARTMENT THAT HAS A
VERY UNSPECIFIC CONSTRICTS
STRUCTURE IN TERMS OF HOW WE.
INTERACT WITH THE LEGISLATURE IN
TERMS OF LEGISLATION AND
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE.
IT BECOMES MURKY AND
CHALLENGING.
ESPECIALLY GIVEN THAT THE SOLE
PURPOSE OF THE SENIOR
LEGISLATURE IS TO IDENTIFY AND
AS JOHN POINTER VIEW NO MENTION
LAST TIME SHOP.
LEGISLATIVE PROPOSALS TO THE TO
LEGISLATORS DIRECTLY AND HAVE
THAT ONGOING INTERACTION WITH
THEM SO.
.
THAT THAT REMAINS OUR
PERSPECTIVE.
I LIVE.
ANY PUBLIC COMMENTS ON ISSUE
ONE.
JANICE BAILEY WITH A CALIFORNIA
SENIOR LEGISLATURE ON THE STAFF
SERVICES MANAGER.
AND WE DO CONTINUE TO SEEK
PLACEMENT OF THE CS ALL OFFICE
WITHIN THE ADMINISTRATION TO
REDUCE COSTS AND PROVIDE
CONTINUITY FOR THE ORGANIZATION.
AND WE ALSO RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
YOUR SUPPORT OF THE BCP BEFORE
YOU TODAY.
THANK YOU.
I'M.
SEEING NO FURTHER PUBLIC COMMENT
BRING UP TO THE DYESS.
I WANTED TO ASK IF I COULD IF
THERE WAS.
I DO UNDERSTAND THE PRESENTATION
DUE TO THEIR ADVOCACY.
BUT I DO WONDER IF THERE IS A
FIRE WALL THAT MAY BE PUT IN
PLACE TO HELP.
PROVIDE THEM THE ADMINISTRATIVE
HELP THEY NEED WITH.
AND MAKING SURE THAT WE'RE
SEPARATING THEIR ADVOCACY FROM
THE WORK THAT YOU DO WITH THE
DEPARTMENT. SO I THINK I WOULD
JUST TAKE THIS BACK AND THEN
I'LL DEFER DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE.
BUT THE GOAL WAS FROM CFLS
PERSPECTIVE
FIND A LOCATION THAT WOULD BE
LESS COSTLY TO THEM IN TERMS OF
THEIR ADMINISTRATIVE SUPPORT.
FOR DEPARTMENT OF AGING TO BE
DOING THAT FOR A LESSER COST.
MEANS THAT WERE ACTUALLY USING
OUR OTHER FUNDING RESOURCES.
TO IN EFFECT
AUGMENT THE NEEDS.
OF THE SENIOR LEGISLATURE.
AND.
WE DO NOT HAVE THE RESOURCES TO
TO DO THAT TYPE OF AUGMENTATION.
SOME WOMEN RUBIO AYE.
I AM NEW HERE BUT.
.
I'M JUST LOOKING AT THE
PRAGMATIC OR THE PRACTICAL
ISSUES LIKE HOUSING NOT
NECESSARILY HOW WOULD THAT TAKE
AWAY FROM YOUR FUNDING IF IT WAS
BASICALLY JUST AN OFFICE. I'M
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT WHAT. YOU
KNOW WHAT WE CAN DO.
SO I'M ENVISIONING THAT IT'S
MORE OF A HOUSING ISSUE. YOU
KNOW WHERE THOSE THE PERSON IS
PLACED AND IF YOU ALREADY HAVE A
BUILDING I DON'T UNDERSTAND HOW
THAT WOULD TAKE AWAY FROM YOUR
OWN. EYE THAT I'M JUST BEING
PRACTICAL HERE AND SO SO IF YOU
CAN EXPLAIN THAT TO ME. I'M IN
TERMS OF A FIREWALL I APPRECIATE
THAT THE YOU CAN SEPARATE THE
ISSUES BUT I'M THINKING HOUSING
WISE.
THAT WOULDN'T NECESSARILY TAKE
AWAY BUT EXPLAIN IT.
CAN YOU EXPLAIN WHAT THE VIEW
THE SUPER LAYMAN'S I'M
APPROACHING FINANCE WILL
PROBABLY GIVE YOU THE MORE
TECHNICAL PROTEST THAT. UP IT'S
NOT JUST A MATTER OF HOUSING AND
ALL THOSE SPACES AND IT'S AN
ISSUE AND OUR DEPARTMENT BUT
IT'S.
YOU KNOW THE SERVICES THE
DEPARTMENT OF GENERAL SERVICES
ARE CURRENTLY PROVIDING INCLUDE
ALL OF THEIR BILLING.
ANY LEGAL CONSULTATION THAT
THEY NEED PERSONNEL.
DEALING WITH PERSONNEL ISSUES
THE FULL RANGE OF I'M SORRY BUT
HOW MANY PERSONAL DO THEY HAVE.
THEY HAVE THEY HAVE WON A STAFF
PERSON IS MY UNDERSTANDING BUT
THEY HAVE A GROUP OF VOLUNTEERS
THAT THEY INTERACT WITH ON A
REGULAR BASIS AND THEN. THE
BOND.
FED DRAWDOWN AND VARIOUS OTHER I
MEAN WE DON'T ACTUALLY EVEN KNOW
THE FULL SCOPE OF WHAT THOSE
ISSUES BUT THOSE ISSUES ARE.
BUT.
THEY WOULD HAVE AND NEED.
ASSISTANCE ON A VARIETY OF
ISSUES ARM RIGHT NOW THEY'RE
BEING CHARGED BY DEPARTMENT
GENERAL SERVICES.
THE STANDARD RATE FOR THOSE
SERVICES THAT WOULD BE WHAT.
PRESUMABLY DEPARTMENT OF FIGHT
OF AGING WOULD.
BE REQUIRING AS WELL AND THE
OTHER BY I THINK ONE OF THE
ISSUES FROM THEIR BCP WAS THAT
THEY DIDN'T WANT. ARM TO HAVE TO
COVER THE STAFFING INCREASED
COSTS FOR THAT POSITION THEY
WANTED KIND OF THE. WAIVER FROM
HAVING TO DO THAT.
MOVING FORWARD IN TERMS OF
THEIR BUDGET.
WE WOULD HAVE NO AUTHORITY TO
NOT DO THAT AND AS A SOMEONE IS
ENOUGH THAT SOMEONE. AND WE'D
HAVE TO ABSORB THE COSTS IF THEY
WERE. AT AT THOSE COSTS WERE WAY
FOR SOME REASON.
REFER TO FINANCE WE ARE MORE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE WE'VE HAD
CONTINUING CONVERSATIONS WITH
THE COMPANY SAN LEGISLATURE
ABOUT THIS ISSUE AT STEMMING
FROM OUR LAST MEETING WITH YOU
ALL. I'M AND.
WE LOOKED NOT ONLY THE
DEPARTMENT OF AGING BUT AT THAT
NUMBER OF OTHER KIND OF MODELS
AND ENTITIES IN THE STATE. AND
THE THE ULTIMATE KIND OF
CONCLUSION IS THAT PICKED CUP
CONTRACTOR FISCAL SERVICES WHICH
IS UNKNOWN APARTMENT GENERAL
SERVICES IF.
AND DO THIS WORK SIGNIFICANTLY
THAT LAST COST AND GENERALLY
CANNOT ABSORB THAT COST BY THEIR
OWN WITHOUT ANY ADDITIONAL
AUGMENTATION.
I'VE CONTRACTED FISCAL SERVICES
EXITS FOR EXACTLY THIS PURPOSE
AND IT ALREADY HAS THAT BUILT IN
FIREWALL BECAUSE IT DOESN'T DEAL
WITH THE.
POLITICAL ISSUES OF WHATEVER
DEPARTMENT MADE TO OR CANNOT
HAVE.
PUMP IT'S GONNA TAKE A LOT MORE
THAN THAT CONVERSATION SO MAYBE
I CAN OUT YOU KNOW I HAVE A
MEETING WITH YOU.
ALL TOUCH MY SCHEDULER TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE BECAUSE I I. JUST I
JUST LOGISTICALLY DOESN'T MAKE
SENSE TO ME AND DIED SO I THINK
IT'S GOING TO TAKE FOR THE
CONVERSATION I'VE LIKE I SAID
I'M VERY PRACTICAL AND FOR ME
IT'S JUST A MATTER OF. YOU KNOW
PUTTING ONE PLACE TO ANOTHER BUT
IT DOESN'T SEEM TO BE THAT.
SIMPLE HERE AND I WANT TO
UNDERSTAND WHY.
THANK YOU.
WITH THAT WE WILL HOLD ISSUE ONE
OPEN AND MOVE ON TO. ISSUE THREE
SINCE ASSEMBLY MEMBER ACOSTA IS
HERE.
THANK YOU.
VERY MUCH.
I DO SHARE AND MIL SOME OF EVER
COOLEY WILL BE JOINING ME
MOMENTARILY HE'S.
I THEY BELIEVE WALKING OVER FOR
ANOTHER FROM ANOTHER COMMITTEE.
SO ALL GET STARTED.
THE BILL TALKS LOW.
HELLO FOLKS CALIFORNIA.
IF YOU WOULD MY WOULD YOU SECURE
POSITION WHO'VE BEEN.
BUT THAT.
I AM I REALLY. GREATLY
APPRECIATE IT AND MY CUTTING.
A CUT IN THE LINES I GUESS I'M
HERE.
OKAY SO.
.
AND WE START OFF CALIFORNIA
FOSTER YOU FACE MANY CHALLENGES
ON AVERAGE STUDENTS IN FOSTER
CARE PERFORM DISPROPORTIONATELY
BOTH SOCIALLY AND ECONOMIC
ECONOMICALLY AND ACADEMICALLY.
IN COMPARISON TO THEIR
CLASSMATES.
A LESS THAN HALF GRADUATE HIGH
SCHOOL AND ONLY THREE TO FIVE
PERCENT GRADUATE FROM FOUR YEAR
COLLEGES.
FOSTER YOUTH ARE ON AVERAGE MORE
LIKELY TO EXPERIENCE SUSPENSIONS
EXPULSIONS AND INTERACTIONS WITH
THE JUVENILE JUSTICE SYSTEM.
WHILE THERE BEEN POLICY EFFORTS
TO IMPROVE THE EDUCATIONAL
OUTCOMES OF FOSTER YOU. WE HAVE
FAILED TO ACT ON THE GROWING
BODY OF RESEARCH INDICATING THE
POSITIVE IMPACT THAT EXTRA
CURRICULAR ENRICHMENT
ACTIVITIES.
SUCH AS SPORTS ART AND MUSIC
PLANE SHAPING A YOUNG PERSON'S
ACADEMIC PERFORMANCE AND OVERALL
WELL BEING.
EXTRACURRICULAR NAME AND
RETRACTED BEES HAVE PROVEN TO
HAVE A POSITIVE IMPACT ON A
YOUNG PERSON'S ATTENDANCE
MOTIVATION ACADEMIC ACHIEVEMENT
SELF ESTEEM AND BEHAVIOR.
HEALTHY RELATIONSHIPS ARE
FOSTERED OUTSIDE THE CLASSROOM
THE PARTICIPATION IN SPORTS
SCHOOL SPONSORED TRIPS AFTER
SCHOOL CLUBS ETCETERA.
THESE BONDS CONTRIBUTE TO A
FOSTER YOUTH SENSE OF BELONGING
AND CONNECTION.
ESPECIALLY WHEN EVIDENCE SHOWS A
SEVENTY PERCENT OF FOSTER YOUTH
EXPERIENCE THE INSTABILITY OF
THREE OR MORE PLACEMENTS.
FURTHERMORE ENRICHMENT
ACTIVITIES ARE AN ESSENTIAL
INGREDIENT FOR ALL HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENTS TO REBEL TO BUILD A
ROBUST AND WELL VERSED COLLEGE
APPLICATION.
THESE ACTIVITIES ALLOW THEM TO
BE MORE COMPETITIVE SO THEY CAN
EVENTUALLY ADVANCE INTO HIGHER
EDUCATION.
OVER A DECADE AGO THE
LEGISLATURE ENACTED A PRUDENT
PARENT STANDARD.
AND THE FOSTER CARE BILL OF
RIGHTS BOTH OF WHICH ESTABLISHED
THE RIGHT OF A FOSTER YOUTH TO
PARTICIPATE IN EXTRACURRICULAR
INDIVIDUAL ACTIVITIES.
DESPITE THIS TRAILBLAZING
BLAZING LEGISLATION THE FUNDING
HAS NOT YET BEEN MADE AVAILABLE
TO GUARANTEE A STUDENT'S
INVOLVEMENT IN THESE ACTIVITIES.
FOSTER CARE GRANT'S OFTEN DO NOT
COVER THE COST OF ART MUSIC
LESSONS SPORTS ACTIVITIES TEST
PREP COURSES SUMMER CAMPS
ETCETERA.
THESE ACTIVITIES PROVIDE A SENSE
OF NORMALCY IN ADDITION TO
DIVERSIFYING THE FOSTER USE
RESUME FOR COLLEGE APPLICATIONS
AND GENERALLY LIFE EXPERIENCE.
WHAT WE PREFER A FULLY FUNDED
STATEWIDE PROGRAM TO THE TUNE OF
FIFTEEN MILLION TWO HUNDRED AND
FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS WE ARE
AMENABLE TO ITS TO INSTITUTING A
LIMITED PILOT PROGRAM?
AS A OUTLINED IN OUR LETTER I AM
REQUESTING AT THE BUDGET
COMMITTEE APPROVES FIVE MILLION
EIGHT HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS. IN ORDER TO
FUND THE FOST YOU THROUGH
RICHARD PILOT PROGRAM FOR LOS
ANGELES SACRAMENTO MERCED AND
IMPERIAL COUNTIES.
THANK THE OPPORTUNITY PRESENT
AND SOME MEMBER COOLEY IS
JOINING ME IN.
WE HAVE SOME.
IF YOU LIKE THAT.
YEAH OF I MAY SPEAK BRIEFLY DO
IT TERRIFIC BILL AYE CHAIR OF
THE SELECT COMMITTEE ON FOSTER
YOUTH.
I THINK THESE EXTRACURRICULAR
ACTIVITIES ARE AN OUTSTANDING
SETTING WHERE. YOUNG PEOPLE CAN.
ENGAGE IN A CONSTRUCTIVE
LEARNING ACTIVITY OF SOME SORT
AND FORM CLOSE FRIENDSHIPS.
AHA. AND.
THOUGH IT THAT'S SORT OF.
DESTRUCTIVE POSITIVE PURPOSEFUL.
AND OF RELATIONSHIP BUILDING.
PHIL PLAYS A VERY IMPORTANT ROLE
THEIR LIFE IT IT HA.
IT JUST GIVES THEM.
AN AREA IN WHICH TO ENJOY
SUCCESS IN CHOI CAMARADERIE IN
CHOI GROWING CLOSE TO OTHER
PEOPLE WHO ARE ALSO WORKING
DATA.
HAVE A GROWING EDGE IN THEIR
LIFE CONCERN IS SOMETHING THEY
LIKE AND LOVE.
IT'S AN EXTREMELY POSITIVE
THING.
AND.
SO I JUST I THINK THIS IS A
TREMENDOUS EFFORT.
AND I THINK WE SHOULD PROVIDE
FUNDING.
YOU KNOW.
THE MOST PRECIOUS THING IN A
CHILD'S LIFE IS TO HAVE TIME
THAT THEY CAN GROW
CONSTRUCTIVELY.
AND THIS PROVIDES YOU TREMENDOUS
SETTING WHERE WHEN THEY'RE IN
SCHOOL FRIENDSHIPS GROWING EDGE.
.
CONSTRUCTIVE ENGAGEMENT WHICH IS
VERY POSITIVE.
AND SO I THINK YOU FOR THE
INITIATIVE. AND THE.
I STRONGLY SUPPORT IT.
THANK YOU TO WHOEVER COOLEY NEXT
WE HAVE LUCY SAUCEDO CARTER.
THANK YOU.
AB I'M THE POLICY ADVOCATE WITH
THE YOUTH LAW CENTER.
THE YOUTH LAW CENTER ADVOCATES
TO TRANSFORM THE JUVENILE
JUSTICE AND CHILD WELFARE SYSTEM
SO THAT ALL CHILDREN CAN THRIVE.
AND WE'RE SUPPORTING THIS
PROPOSAL.
I'M BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT IT WILL
HELP FOSTER CHILDREN TO HAVE THE
NORMAL EXPERIENCE OF
PARTICIPATING IN ENRICHMENT
ACTIVITIES.
THIS IS A NORMAL EXPERIENCE A I
WANT TO EMPHASIZE NORMAL THAT IS
SO VITAL FOR A HEALTHY CHILD
CHILD DEVELOPMENT AND YET IT IS
SO OFTEN DENIED.
FOSTER YOU BECAUSE OF COST
ANOTHER BARRIERS.
CALIFORNIA AND FEDERAL LAWS
REQUIRE THAT ALL YOUTH IN FOSTER
CARE BE ABLE TO PARTICIPATE IN
AGE AND DEVELOPMENTALLY
APPROPRIATE ENRICHMENT
ACTIVITIES.
YET COST IS A KEY BARRIER.
FOR EXAMPLE AND ACTIVITY COULD
COST SOMETHING LIKE SIX HUNDRED
DOLLARS LET'S SAY. AND IF YOU'VE
GOT A COUPLE OF CHILDREN IN YOUR
FAMILY AND THEY WANT TO ENGAGE
IN MULTIPLE ACTIVITIES YOU CAN
SEE HOW THAT ADDS UP VERY
QUICKLY. I'M AN EXISTING FOSTER
CARE.
FUNDING.
THE FOSTER CARE PAYMENTS
DOES NOT EXPLICITLY GO TOWARDS
THESE EXTRACURRICULAR
ACTIVITIES.
SO ALTHOUGH OUR LAWS.
REQUIRED PARTICIPATION.
WE'RE NOT REALLY PUTTING OUR
MONEY WHERE OUR MOUTHS ARE ON
THIS ONE.
TO QUOTE ONE FOSTER PARENT.
IT'S ALMOST OFFENSIVE FOR
SOMEONE TO SAY IT'S SO IMPORTANT
FOR YOU TO ENROLL THEM.
BUT IT'S GOING TO COST YOU YOUR
WHOLE BUDGET FOR THE WHOLE YEAR.
AND OTHER WORDS ARE LOS MAKE
CLEAR HOW IMPORTANT ENRICHMENT
ACTIVITIES ARE TO NORMALCY AND
WELL BEING. FOR FOSTER YOUTH BUT
OUR PAYMENT STRUCTURES DO NOT
SUPPORT CARE GIVERS PROVIDING
THESE VITAL ACTIVITIES.
AND YET WE'VE HEARD ALREADY
ABOUT THE POTENTIAL BENEFITS OF
THESE ACTIVITIES I'M JUST GONNA
GIVE A COUPLE OF. EXAMPLES GOING
A LITTLE DEEPER INTO THE
RESEARCH AND WHAT IT SAYS.
YOUTH PARTICIPATION IN AFTER
SCHOOL ACTIVITIES IS ASSOCIATED
WITH BETTER ACHIEVEMENT TEST
SCORES BETTER GRADES AND HIGHER
GRADUATION RATES.
YOUTH PARTICIPATION IN RICHMOND
ACTIVITIES HELPS YOUNG PEOPLE
CULTIVATE SOFT SKILLS.
SUCH IS THE ABILITY TO WORK WITH
OTHERS TAKE LEADERSHIP AND
EXERCISE SELF DISCIPLINE.
I TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN STUDY
FOUND THAT EXTRA CURRICULAR
ACTIVITIES AND STILL THE SKILLS
AND VALUES.
THAT MATTER FOR CAREER SUCCESS.
OPPORTUNITY THIS TO CONNECT WITH
SUPPORTIVE ADULTS AND
PARTICIPATE WITH PEERS IN
MEANINGFUL ACTIVITIES.
HAVE BEEN SHOWN TO HELP YOUTH
DEVELOP NEW SKILLS AND PERSONAL
TALENTS.
YOU THINK GAUGE AN EXTRA
CURRICULAR PROGRAMMING REDUCE
RISKY AND PROBLEM BEHAVIOR AND
OFTEN BECOME INVOLVED IN
IMPROVING THEIR COMMUNITIES.
AND FINALLY SUPPORTIVE
RELATIONSHIPS WITH ADULTS CAN
MITIGATE THE PHYSIOLOGICAL
EFFECTS ON CHILDREN OF EXPOSURE
TO TRAUMA AND WE KNOW THAT MOST
OF THESE YOUNG PEOPLE HAVE BEEN
EXPOSED TO TRAUMA. EITHER BEFORE
THEIR INVOLVEMENT WITH THE
SYSTEM AND OR.
BECAUSE OF THEIR INVOLVEMENT
WITH THE SYSTEM.
SO WITH IS JUST AN EXAMPLE OF
WHAT THE RESEARCH HAS TO SAY ON
THIS TOPIC.
AND.
WE NO THAT FOR HEALTHY
DEVELOPMENT YOUNG PEOPLE NEED TO
BE.
EMBEDDED IN NETWORKS OF FAMILIES
FRIENDS AND COMMUNITIES THAT
WILL PROVIDE THEM WITH THE
GUIDANCE AND SUPPORT AND HELP
THAT THEY NEED.
UNFORTUNATELY THE SYSTEM OFTEN
DISCONNECTS YOUTH.
FROM THE SUPPORTIVE NETWORKS.
ENRICHMENT ACTIVITIES HELP YOUNG
PEOPLE REBUILD THE SUPPORTIVE
RELATIONSHIPS THAT THEY NEED
AND DEVELOP A SENSE OF
BELONGING.
ALSO THIS INVESTMENT IN
ENRICHMENT ACTIVITIES FOR FOSTER
YOUTH THE SMALL.
COMPARED TO THE LONG TERM HUMAN
AND FINANCIAL COSTS OF POOR
OUTCOMES
FOR FOSTER YOUTH.
WHEN THEY DO NOT HAVE THESE
EXPERIENCES
TO THRIVE SO FOR THESE REASONS
WE SUPPORT THIS BUDGET ASKING
RESPECTFULLY ASK THAT YOU
SUPPORT IT TO FAKE.
HE CAME.
NEXT WE HAVE PLAYED THOSE
STRIPE.
HI MY NAME IS PLATO'S STRAY CAT
AM I AM CURRENTLY. WORKING WITH
K. CALIFORNIA'S CONNECTION OF
THE POLICY ADMINISTRATIVE
COORDINATOR.
TODAY I COME TO BRING MY
TESTIMONY AT.
AND.
SO WHEN I WAS IN SCHOOL I WAS
UNABLE TO JOIN US AND AFTER
SCHOOL PROGRAMS AND JUST BECAUSE
THE FUNDING IN TRANSPORTATION.
ADD TO AND FROM NEEDS IN GAMES
AYE I FELT LEFT OUT AND CONFINED
BECAUSE OF MY.
BECAUSE OF NOT BEING ABLE TO
PARTICIPATE IN EVERYTHING THAT
THAT OTHER KIDS WERE ABLE TO
PARTAKE IN.
.
JUST SAID. PERHAPS A BIT THE
SCHOOL BAND DRAMA CLUB OR ANY
SPORT MAY BE AN ACTIVITY ARE
FAST YOU ARE INTERESTED IN
JOINING BY ALLOWING FOR US TO
USE THE OPPORTUNITY TO EXPLORE
DIVERSE INTERESTS TO GIVE THEM
THE OPPORTUNITY. TO DISCOVER
WHAT THEY'RE PASSIONATE ABOUT
ONCE YOU'RE HAD CHILDREN FIND AN
ACTIVITY THAT THEY ENJOY
SUCCEEDING IS IN AND THE
ACTIVITY COULD ULTIMATELY. BUILD
THE CONFIDENCE AND SELF ESTEEM.
ANOTHER BENEFIT OF AFTER SCHOOL
ACTIVITIES IS THAT. THEY LOOK.
GREAT ON COLLEGE APPLICATIONS IN
ADDITION TO ACADEMIC
PERFORMANCE.
MANY COLLEGES LOOK AT WHAT
ACTIVITIES SCHOOL THAT STUDENTS
ARE INVOLVED IN OUTSIDE OF
SCHOOL AS A WAY TO FULLY
UNDERSTAND EACH STUDENT.
I THINK THAT.
STUDENT SOCIAL LIFE IS JUST AS
IMPORTANT AS THEIR ACABAN
ACADEMIC LIFE PREPARED
DEVELOPMENT STUDIES.
SO CORRELATION BETWEEN IMPROVED
GRADES BEHAVIOR AND WORK HABITS
AS A RESULT AND AFTER SCHOOL
ACTIVITIES AND THAT I URGE YOU
TO SUPPORT US.
THANK YOU SIR.
NEXT WE HAVE VALERIE EARLY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR VALERIE
EARLY WITH DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES WE HAVE NO FORMAL
POSITION ON THIS.
PROPOSAL.
BUT IF THIS BECOMES A
DEFINITELY A LEGISLATIVE
PRIORITY WE WILL WORK WITH. THEM
TO MAKE THIS WORK WELL. THANK
YOU MA'AM.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE LA OF.
LIAM WHERE DEPART FINANCE.
ECHOING MY DEPARTMENT
COUNTERPART WE'RE HAPPY TO
PROVIDE TECHNICAL.
THANK YOU MA'AM ANY PUBLIC
COMMENT ON ISSUE THREE.
FRANK MAKO WITH THE COUNTY
WELFARE DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION
THIS AS A REALLY GOOD PROPOSAL
AND WE I STRONGLY URGE YOUR
SUPPORT.
JESSE I GO WITH JOURNEY HOUSE.
STRONG SUPPORT.
MIKE SEGURA NO AFFILIATION I
HIRED YOU AND ALL THE SMART
PEOPLE IN SUPPORT THE BILL.
THANK YOU SIR.
I THINK NO FURTHER PUBLIC
COMMENT TO BRING IT UP TO THE
DYESS FOR ANY COMMENTS.
SEEING NONE I WANT TO THANK BOTH
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ACOSTA AND
ASSEMBLYMEMBER COOLEY FOR BRING
IN THIS IMPORTANT MEASURE
FORWARD. AT THIS TIME WE WILL
HOLD IT OPEN AND THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PRESENTATION HERE TODAY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH CHAIR
MEMBERS PRECIADO.
WE WILL NOW RETURN TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF REHABILITATION AND
START WITH IS YOU ISSUE OR ONE
.
GOOD AFTERNOON KELLY HER DEPUTY
DIRECTOR FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF REHABILITATION.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
ROUGHLY GOMEZ ON THE ASSISTANT
DEPUTY DIRECTOR FOR SPECIALIZED
SERVICES DIVISION.
I REMOTELY LA DEPARTMENT OF
REHABILITATION OF INDEPENDENT
LIVING COMMUNITY ACCESS
DIVISION.
THANK YOU ALL PROVIDE AN
OVERVIEW OVERVIEW OF THE THREE
OUT OF SPRING FINANCE REQUESTS
THAT WE HAVE. WHICH REQUEST NO
GENERAL FUND.
PRIMARILY.
SPENDING AUTHORITY AND THEN MY
COLLEAGUES HERE I'M ARE
AVAILABLE IF YOU WOULD LIKE MORE
DETAIL OR HER HAVE QUESTIONS.
BOB OUR.
THREE REQUESTS.
ARE RELATED TO BOTH OF
VOCATIONAL REHABILITATION
PROGRAM THAT WE PROVIDE FOR
VENDORS WHO ARE BLIND. AND IT'S
INTENDED TO PROVIDE THEM WITH A
LIVING WAGE
SO AMONG OTHER THINGS THAT WE DO
TO PROVOCATIVE I'M SUPPORT THE
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE BLIND OR BUY
THEM EQUIPMENT.
REPAIR THEIR EQUIPMENT PREPARE
SITES ON STATE PROPERTY COUNTY
PROPERTY WHEN AVAILABLE FEDERAL
PROPERTY.
AND UP PROMOTE THEIR BUSINESSES
SO THAT THEY. YOU KNOW THEY CAN
MAXIMIZE THEIR.
THEIR LIVING WAGE.
AND THE FIRST REQUEST IS FOR.
SPENDING AUTHORITY TO MATCH THE
FUNDS THAT WE ALREADY HAVE THE
SPECIAL FUNDS IN THE FEDERAL
FUNDS THAT WE CAN USE. OUGHT TO
BUY THEM EQUIPMENT WITHOUT THE
ADDITIONAL AUTHORITY WE WOULD
HAVE TO USE FUNDS FROM THAT ARE
REALLY NEEDED FOR OTHER
VOCATIONAL REHABILITATION. THE
AYE VENDING FACILITY FUND IS
COMPRISED OF ON.
A PORTION OF PROFITS THAT THE
VENDORS MUST.
CONTRIBUTE TOWARDS THE
EQUIPMENT AND THE REPAIRS UNDER
FEDERAL LAW SO THE FUNDS ARE
THERE AND I IT'S JUST THAT ARE
SPENDING AUTHORITY IS NOT AS
HIGH AS IT NEEDS TO BE SO WE'RE
ASKING FOR. A MILLION DOLLARS
WHICH RESTORES AT TWO AT
THIRTEEN FOURTEEN BUDGET OFFER
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN AND ANNUALLY
THEREAFTER.
THE SECOND NO PLEASE OKAY AND
THE SECOND REQUEST THAT WE HAVE
ALSO. FOR.
SPENDING AUTHORITY AYE ME STOP
YOU THERE BECAUSE OF HAVING ON
TO ISSUE TO INTEREST PER SECOND
SEEING I'M MASS DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE AND AYE LEO TO COMMENT
ON THE ISSUE.
JENNY BELLOW AT THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE WE'VE REVIEWED
THIS SPRING FINANCE LETTER IN
THE OTHER TWO THAT YOU'LL BE IN
REVIEWING NEXT AND WE HAVE NO
CONCERNS TO RAISE. THAT SAID WE
ARE AWARE OF SOME QUESTIONS AT
THAT THE DEPARTMENTS IN THE
PROCESS OF IT OF ANSWERING FOR
SOME. MEMBERS OF THE LEGISLATIVE
STAFF THAT WE AGREE WITH THE
STAFF RECOMMENDATION BELIEVE
OPEN AT THIS POINT. CREEK.
REPUBLICAN ANTHONY ISSUE ONE.
SEEING NONE.
WE WILL HOLD ISSUE ONE OPEN AND
MOVE ON TO ISSUE TOO. OKAY THANK
YOU AND THEIR SECOND REQUEST IN
ITS.
FOR TWO MILLION DOLLARS IN
REIMBURSEMENT AUTHORITY OVER THE
NEXT TWO YEARS. AB TO SUPPORT
INDIVIDUALS.
TO AFFORD INDIVIDUALS.
INDEPENDENCE.
.
THE INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE
DISABILITIES THAT ARE SPEECH
RELATED SO THAT WE CAN WORK WITH
THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION. TO EVALUATE
INDIVIDUALS WHO NEED.
SPEECH GENERATING DEVICES
SO THAT THEY CAN USE THE
TELEPHONE.
THE IT DEPARTMENT WILL USE
EXISTING TEMPORARY HEALTH HELP
POSITION ALLOCATIONS FOR THE
DURATION OF THE PILOT WOULD
ENTER INTO AN INTERAGENCY
AGREEMENT WITH THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION AND
THAT PROVIDE FUNDING TO A
VARIETY OF ORGANIZATIONS
INCLUDING INDEPENDENT LIVING
CENTERS. THAT.
EVALUATE INDIVIDUALS WHO NEED
THIS TYPE OF EQUIPMENT YOU CAN
BENEFIT FROM THIS EQUIPMENT AND
THAT PROVIDED TO THEM.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE ILIO
INCUMBENTS.
ANY PUBLIC COMMENTS ON ISSUE TO.
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS
SUBCOMMITTEE HENNER CONTROLLERS
WITH THE CALIFORNIA FOUNDATION
FOR INDEPENDENT LIVING CENTERS.
WE ADMINISTERED THE PILOT
PROGRAM IN CONJUNCTION WITH TEN
VOICE OPTIONS PROGRAMS.
AND ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WE'VE
LEARNED IS THAT THERE'S A FAIRLY
BIG LEARNING CURVE TO USE THE
TECHNOLOGY PROMOTE. INDEPENDENT
LIVING SO THERE'S A LOT OF HANDS
ON A CONSULTATION IS NEEDED AND
IT DEFINITELY HELPS TO HAVE THE
DEPARTMENT OF. REALIZATION TAKE
ON THIS RESPONSIBILITY BECAUSE
THEY DO HAVE THE NECESSARY
EXPERTISE ON ASSISTIVE
TECHNOLOGY INDEPENDENT LIVING.
SO WE HAD SUPPORT. THANK YOU
SIR.
SIGNAL FOR THE PUBLIC COMMENT
ARE BRING IT UP TO THE DYESS FOR
ANY COMMENTS SEEING NONE WE WILL
HOLD ISSUE TO OPEN AND MOVE ON
TO ISSUE THREE. THAT THANK YOU.
THIRD.
REQUEST AS TO AUTHORIZE.
.
DEAL ARE TO ENTER INTO
AGREEMENTS WITH PRIVATE AND
PUBLIC BUSINESSES TO PROVIDE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE FOR THE
BENEFIT OF PEOPLE. WITH
DISABILITIES IN THE COMMUNITY
AMONG OUR OTHER.
RESPONSIBILITIES THE DEPARTMENT
AND.
GOVERNMENT CODE IS CHARGED WITH
EDUCATING THE PUBLIC AND DOING
WHAT WE CAN TO SUPPORT PRIVATE
PUBLIC BUSINESSES TO MAKE. DOM.
THEIR BUSINESSES AND THE
COMMUNITY ACCESSIBLE FOR PEOPLE
WITH DISABILITIES WE ALWAYS HAVE
A GREATER AMOUNT A REQUEST TO
PROVIDE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE AND
SUPPORT THEN WE HAVE FUNDING. WE
ENTER INTO AGREEMENTS WHERE
THOSE WHO WERE PROVIDING THE
ASSISTANCE TO WILL REIMBURSE US
FOR COST SO AGAIN THIS IS NOT A
GENERAL FUND ASK IT'S JUST FOUR
HUNDRED THOUSAND.
FOR NEXT YEAR AND RECURRING AND
FOR BUDGET AUTHORITY AND.
FOR THREE PERMANENT POSITIONS
THAT WILL BE FUNDED ALSO WITH
REIMBURSEMENT.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE TO LEO.
I'M JUST WAITING TO THE END US
SO THE PART OF FIND SUPPORTS ALL
THREE PROPOSALS FOR THE REASONS
STATED BY DEPARTMENT THANK YOU.
ANY PUBLIC COMMENT ON THE ISSUE
THREE.
XENON I'LL BRING IT UP TO THE
DYESS
IF YOU'LL INDULGE ME BOB MISS
GOMEZ I WAS WONDERING IF. YOU
COULD TELL US THE NAME OF YOUR.
PUPPY WHO'S HERE OR US YEAH HER
NAME IS DOLLA. DOLLA YES WELL
THAT'S BEAUTIFUL.
THANK YOU WITH THAT WE WILL HOLD
ISSUE THREE OPEN AND.
.
MOVE ON TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
SOCIAL SERVICES THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
WE NEED
.
GOOD AFTERNOON DISTRIBUTOR KERN
DICKERSON DEPUTY DIRECTOR
WITH DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES.
WE ARE REQUESTING TO HEAR
LIMITED TERM FUNDING TO SUPPORT
FOR POSITIONS IN OUR ESTIMATES
BUREAU IN SUPPORT OF OUR IN HOME
SUPPORTIVE SERVICES PROGRAM.
THE CHANGES IN THE I JUST AS
PROGRAM THAT REQUIRE THIS
ADDITIONAL STAFF SUPPORT.
INCLUDE WORKLOAD ASSOCIATED WITH
PROVIDING COST ESTIMATES AND
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE TO COUNTIES
ON PROPOSALS AS THEY ENTER INTO
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING. NEGOTIATE
WAGES FOR I JUST S. WORKERS AND
THEIR RESPECTIVE COUNTIES.
WE ARE ALSO A NEW REQUIREMENT IS
FOR OUR DEPARTMENT TO ALSO
APPROVE WAGE PLAN SUBMITTED BY
COUNTIES FOR COMPLIANCE WITH
STATE LAW.
SAID THE COMPLEXITY OF THESE
AGREEMENTS IS BASS.
TAKING INTO CONSIDERATION
CHANGES IN MINIMUM WAGE COUNTY
AND STATE SHARING AGREEMENTS.
NEGOTIATED COUNTY WAGE
SUPPLEMENTS.
EACH PROPOSAL IS UNIQUE AND
TAKES A CONSIDERABLE AMOUNT OF
TIME AND EFFORT BACK AND FORTH
WITH COUNTIES.
AND I AM ARE COUNTY PARTNERS.
ALSO FOLLOWING PLAN APPROVAL
ISSUING COUNTY LETTERS TRACKING
ACTUAL EXPENDITURES TO ENSURE
COMPLIANCE IS ALSO PART OF THE
ADDITIONAL TASKS THAT WERE
TAKING ON.
WE ARE REQUESTING LIMITED TERM
FUNDING AS THE COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING PROCESS DOES SUNSET
ON JANUARY TWENTY TWENTY.
EXISTING STAFF HAVE THE AT WORK
A GREAT DEAL OVER TIME AND
AREN'T ABLE TO TAKE ON THIS
ADDITIONAL WORK LOAD.
SO THE LIMITED TERM FUNDING WILL
ENABLE US TO SUPPORT OUR COUNTY
IN STAKEHOLDER PARTNERS IN
UNDERSTANDING AND QUANTIFYING
THIS NEW FUNDING STRUCTURE.
THANK YOU VICUNA DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE ELLIOTT.
I'M JACKI BRAZIL BUT THE
LEGITIMACY ANALYST'S OFFICE
AGAIN WERE IN PAIN BURST OF
REVIEWING THE I'M SORRY SPRING
FINANCE LETTER BUT AS OF NOW NO
MAJOR CONCERNS TO RAISE BUT AS
WE CONTINUE TO REVIEW IT AND IF.
I'M. ANY ADDITIONAL INFORMATION
WILL BE HELPFUL WILL MATURE
SHIRGAH. THINK EMMA.
ANY PUBLIC COMMENT ON ISSUE ONE.
YEAH I KEVIN AS THE CHORUS OF
TELEPHONE WELFARE RIGHTS
ORGANIZATION ESTIMATES.
BILL HAS BEEN VERY HELPFUL TO
STAKEHOLDER TH
AND WITH SUPPORTIVE BCP.
THING AT THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION
COUNTIES ALONG WITH THAT COUNTY
WELFARE DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION
HOW.
THE PUBLIC AUTHORITIES WE
SUBMITTED A SUPPORT LETTER ON.
THIS ADDITIONAL FUNDING
RESOURCES WILL HELP ENSURE THAT
THE DEPARTMENT CAN PROVIDE
ACCURATE AND TIMELY.
GUIDANCE TO COUNTIES ON ALL THE
SITES SUCH CHANGES AS WELL AS
TIMELY REVIEW OF THE COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING AGREEMENTS THAT ARE
SUBMITTED AND SO FOR THOSE
REASONS WE SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
FUNKY DAMARCUS WITH UW OFFICE
MIRACLE THIRTY NINE THIRTY HAPPY
TO SUPPORT THE STAFFING ACROSS
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MA'AM.
SEEING NO FURTHER PUBLIC COMMENT
TO BRING IT UP TO THE DYESS FOR
ANY QUESTIONS THAT WE MAY HAVE.
SEEING NONE WE WILL HOLD ISSUE
ONE OPEN AND THANK YOU FOR
COMING.
WILL NOW BEGIN WITH ISSUE TO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER QUIRK MAYBE
JOINING US IF I MAY ASK THE
ADVOCATES TO COME AND PRESENT.
AND A SURPLUS CYCLE ME I ALREADY
ON.
COOPER FIRST ATTEMPT TO.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR OF RUMBLE
LA AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
MY NAME IS SONNY SET BY SO
CALLED BE AFTER YOU AND I AM THE
POLICY DIRECTOR FOR THE ALAMEDA
COUNTY SOCIAL SERVICES AGENCY.
ALAMEDA COUNTY IS HONORED TO BE
WORKING CLOSELY WITH ASSEMBLY
MEMBER QUIRK.
AND THE WESTERN CENTER ON LAW
AND POVERTY TO BRING FOR THIS
BUDGET PROPOSAL.
CURRENTLY THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA IS ACCOUNTING.
OUR STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
AND A COUNTY CAN MAKE A
DETERMINATION THAT A SPONSORED
NON CITIZEN WOULD GO HUNGRY. AND
HOMELESS WITHOUT AID.
AND DETERMINE HIM OR HER TO BE
INDIGENT.
FOR YOUR REFERENCE CAL FRESH AND
CAL WORKS INDIGENCE
DETERMINATIONS ARE ONLY VALID
FOR A TWELVE MONTH PERIOD.
AND CAL FRESH PROGRAM THESE
DETERMINATIONS ARE RENEWABLE
ANNUALLY WITHOUT RESTRICTIONS.
HOWEVER IN CAL WORKS
THERE IS NO PROVISION FOR
RENEWAL. AN INDIGENT EXCEPTION
MAY ONLY BE GRANTED ONCE IN A
SPONSORED NON CITIZENS LIFETIME.
REMOVING UNNECESSARY BARRIERS TO
SUPPORT INTO ENGINE IMMIGRANTS
IT'S CRITICAL.
ESPECIALLY NOW DURING A TIME OF
FEDERAL UNCERTAINTY.
IT IS OUR UNDERSTANDING THAT THE
INTENTION EXCEPTION FOR
SPONSORED NON CITIZENS IS THE
REGULATION BUT IS A HUNDRED
PERCENT STATE FUNDED.
IN ALAMEDA COUNTY THIS WOULD
MEAN ASSISTING LESS THAN FORTY
INDIVIDUALS A YEAR TO RECEIVE
THIS BENEFIT.
TO GET A GENERAL SENSE OF THE
IMPACTED POPULATION WE REACHED
OUT TO OUR NEIGHBORING COUNTIES.
FOR DATA FOR FISCAL YEAR SIXTEEN
SEVENTEEN.
IN RESPONSE WE RECEIVED
INFORMATION FROM THE FOLLOWING
COUNTIES.
FOR MONTEREY.
THIRTY FOUR.
FOR FRESNO TWO HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY THREE.
FOR SAN FRANCISCO A HUNDRED AND
FOURTEEN.
WHILE SMALL IN NUMBER IT WOULD
HELP OUR COMMUNITIES
TREMENDOUSLY.
WITH YOUR INDULGENCE I'D LIKE TO
READ INTO THE RECORD TESTIMONY
FROM AN ALAMEDA COUNTY CLIENT.
WHO WAS HESITANT TO COME
FORWARD?
OUT OF FEAR OF THE GOVERNMENT
BUT WANTED TO SHARE HIS STORY.
MY NAME IS MISTER PRESCOTT.
I RIDE TO THE UNITED STATES FROM
TONGA WITH MY WIFE AND CHILD. AS
SPONSORED NON CITIZENS AND TWO
THOUSAND TWELVE.
I WAS GAINFULLY EMPLOYED. UNTIL
ONE TRAGIC MORNING IN TWO
THOUSAND FIFTEEN WHEN GETTING
READY FOR WORK I SUFFERED A
STROKE.
HAVING LIMITED RESOURCES AND
KNOW CONTACT WITH MY SPONSOR I
APPLIED FOR CAL WORKS.
THE AID REALLY HELPED ME WHEN WE
HAD NO OTHER INCOME.
BUT THE CASH WAS CUT OFF AFTER
ONE YEAR.
AND WE SUFFERED.
WE COULD NO LONGER PAY OUR RENT.
OR ARE BILLS.
I HAVE TO FIND ANOTHER SOURCE OF
INCOME EVEN THOUGH I WAS STILL
RECUPERATING FROM MY STRIP.
FINDING EMPLOYMENT WITH A
CHALLENGE AS MY PHYSICAL
ABILITIES WERE LIMITED.
IT WAS HEARTBREAKING TO SEE MY
CHILD AND WIFE SUFFER.
TODAY I AM LUCKY TO HAVE A JOB.
BUT IF I LOSE MY JOB.
I'M ONLY ONE PAYCHECK AWAY FROM
LOSING MY HOME.
PROPOSALS LIKE VIS.
WELL HELP US PROVIDE THE BASIC
NECESSITIES FOR A FAMILIES.
PLEASE
HELP US PASSED THIS SO THAT OUR
CHILDREN CAN HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO
STEVE IN THIS COUNTRY.
IN CLOSING.
NO HUMAN.
SHOULD HAVE TO FACE THE
POSSIBILITY OF GOING HOMELESS OR
HUNGRY INCLUDING IMMIGRANTS.
PLEASE HELP PROTECT THE
PRESCOTT'S OF OUR STATE.
THANK YOU FOR ATTACK.
GIVEN.
IT KEVIN AS THE COALITION
CALIFORNIA WELFARE RIGHTS
ORGANIZATION.
IT'S HARD TO ADD MUCH TO THAT
EXCEPT THAT THE WE'VE SEEN.
OF PEOPLE HAVE SPONSORS IN OF TO
SPONSOR DIES OF THE SPONSOR
BECOMES ABUSED SERVE OR THIS
BONTA BECOMES DISABLED IN THIS.
THE THEN THE SPONSORSHIP WILL
DOESN'T APPLY.
AND THE THIRD CATEGORY WITH
SPONSORS ABANDONED.
THE PERSON THAT THIS BOTH
SPONSOR FOR THEM THERE'S THE
INVENTIONS EXCEPTION.
AND FOR SOME WITHIN CALIFORNIA
AFTER TWELVE MONTHS TO JUST DUMP
YOUR.
BUT THEN LIKE CAL WORK THEY
SHOULD BE DETERMINED EVERY
TWELVE MONTHS.
C. APPEARS TO ELIGIBLE THE FOLKS
WHO GET THE TELL WORKS THE HAVE
TO PARTICIPATE WELL PUT TO WORK
IN MOST OF THEM FIND A JOB
PRETTY SOON. AND THEY NEVER HAVE
TO BE SUBJECT REPORT MONTH WITH
DETERMINATION BUT SOME DO. UP
BECAUSE OF THE LANGUAGE SKILLS
THEY STILL HAVE TO LEARN THE
LANGUAGE
TO BE ABLE TO SURVIVE. SOBRE
URGENT ADOPTION OF THIS THANK
YOU THANK YOU SIR.
THE CHEN MEMBERS CAN JOHNSON
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT SOCIAL
SERVICES WE WOULD JUST ALSO
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT THERE IS A
DIFFERENCE IN THE POLICY IN
TERMS OF COW FRESHEN CAO WORKS.
I'M AND IF THIS BECOMES A
PRIORITY LEGISLATURE HAPPY THEIR
WORK WITH AT
STAKEHOLDERS HERE ON A SOLUTION.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE EARLIER.
YEAH IT WAS FINE IF WE HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO ANALYZE THIS
PROPOSAL YET WE DON'T.
I DON'T HAVE AN ESTIMATE AT THE
MOMENT BUT THE COST WOULD BE.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAT ALMOST THE
LA L..
WE'VE REVIEWED THAT SORT OF
FIRST LOOK AT THIS PROPOSAL
WE'RE DISCUSSING IT WITH THE
AUTHORS OFFICE WITH COMMITTEE
STAFF WITH THAT. THE COUNTIES
THERE THERE ARE A BUNCH OF
STAKEHOLDERS INVOLVED AND ARE
ARE HAPPY TO BE WORKING WITH YOU
OF THE NEXT SEVERAL WEEKS TO GET
A BETTER SENSE OF. THE SIZE THE
SCOPE SOME THE DATA NEEDS WE
MIGHT NEED TO GET A BETTER
ASSESSMENT THIS PROPOSAL.
THANK YOU SIR.
REPUBLICAN ANTHONY ISSUE TO.
SEEING NONE OF THEM HELP BRING
IT UP TO THE DYESS FRONT
QUESTIONS THAT WE MAY HAVE.
I WOULD APPRECIATE THE
INFORMATION AS IT BECOMES
AVAILABLE FOR US TO. MAKE OUR
DECISIONS BUT THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS PROPOSAL FORWARD
AND WITH THAT WE WILL HOLD THIS
ISSUE OPEN AND THAT COMPLETES
TODAY'S SOMEONE HERE. THANK YOU
ALL THINK